ONE BILL THAT WAS PULLED FROM
TODAY'S HEARING THAT'S AB.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN ITEM -- THREE
WE ALSO HAVE. EIGHT ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- SORRY SEVEN
CAN'T COUNT -- SEVEN ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- THOSE
ARE AB ONE SIXTY FOUR AB.
ONE EIGHTY NINE AB.
FOR FIFTEEN AB.
FIVE EIGHTY ONE AB TWELVE SIXTY
ONE ACTUALLY THAT ONE'S ON
CONTENT TO MORE SORRY -- TOOLS
OR ANYTHING DID KNOW HOW TO
COUNT -- AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE
WHICH IS ITEM SEVENTEEN WILL NOT
BE ON CONSENT SO BUT EVERYTHING
ELSE I JUST STATED.
AND AB.
TWELVE NINETY TWO AB FOURTEEN
NINETY THREE AND AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE SO THOSE
ARE CONSENT -- AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST BILL WHICH IS
ITEM ONE A. B..
TWELVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- WHEN?
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN HAS A THREE
BILL SO WE'LL HEAR THE MALL.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED THIS MORNING 2% AB
TWELVE AND WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE BILL.
THIS BILL MAKES A NUMBER OF
CHANGES TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL THAT WAS CREATED AND HAS
BEEN CHAMPIONED BY THE CHAIR
SENATOR SKINNER.
AB TWELVE PROVIDES JUDICIAL
DISCRETION TO SET THE TIME
PERIOD FOR A G. V. R. O. AFTER
NOTICING HEARING FROM ONE YEAR.
UP TO FIVE YEARS THIS WILL
ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN ON COURTS
FAMILIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO
CURRENTLY MUST EXTEND GP ARE
OWES ON A YEARLY BASIS.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES THREE OTHER
CLARIFICATIONS THAT MAKE GDR
OWES MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE BY ALLOWING AGENCIES
TO FILE IN LIEU OF NAMING
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS THAT ARE
REQUESTING OFFICER MAY SERVE THE
ORDER.
AND THAT ALLOWANCES FOR SALE AND
TRANSFER DO NOT APPLY IN
EMERGENCY CONTACTS WHILE THESE
CHANGES WOULD NOT HAVE STOPPED
THE EVENTS OF THE BORDER LINE
HAS A BORDERLINE SHOOTING IN MY
DISTRICT.
IT IS MY BELIEF THAT BY
STRENGTHENING AND REFINING OUR
EXISTING GUN LAWS WE CAN HELP TO
PREVENT ANOTHER COMMUNITY FROM
EXPERIENCING THE HORROR OF A
NATIONAL THING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE THOUGH --
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER
ORGANISED W. QUORUM BEFORE WE
HEAR FROM YOUR WITNESSES -- CAN
WE HAVE THE ROLL CALL PLEASE
[inaudible]
SKINNER.
I'M HERE YOUR HEAR MORE LACK.
WELL I CARE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HERE.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE CAN HEAR FROM
YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT INTERMEMBRANE DAMSELS ON
BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THIS BILL MAKES COMMONSENSE
CHANGES WE SIMPLY ASK FOR EUROPE.
OPERATE -- AS OTHER WITNESSES
GET IN LINE -- I WOULD JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU WILL BE
TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS YES THE
ONE I JUST AND QUICKLY MENTION
THOSE [inaudible]
THE THE AMENDMENTS I DON'T HAVE.
OKAY THERE -- IT SAID DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION TILL.
SEPTEMBER FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY
ALONG THE TO SEE.
AND IT WILL BE THE NAMING OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY RATHER
THAN THE NAMING OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INDIVIDUAL.
YES.
OKAY GREAT CLARIFIED THAT NOW
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTIES
OF SANTA CRUZ INVENTOR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS G. V. AIRS --
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS.
WE APPRECIATE THE BILL IN THE
AUTHOR -- FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
SOMETIMES TREATMENT CAN BE MULTI
YEAR.
AND SO THIS BILL BETTER FITS
WITH THAT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THE CARD ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
INCOME TO THE TABLE.
MATTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD IN READ
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU.
FOR CLARIFYING THOSE MOMENTS I
MISSED HIM IN THE ANALYSIS -- SO
JUST TO BE CLEAR IT'S IT'S
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
WHAT ELSE.
HAVING THE NAME OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY ON THE
PETITION RATHER THAN THE
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS NAMES AND
IT'S ACTUALLY IS IN THE HOUSE
OKAY ALL ALL PLEASE BACK THROUGH
THAT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM CHAIR FOR A AGAIN DEEMED
READ FOR THE RECORD WITH NATURAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE.
FOR DINNER IS A CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION --
WORK WITHIN OPPOSED TO G. R.
OWES -- AS IT TAKES AWAY
SOMEONE'S RIGHTS NOT BASED ON A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION OR MENTAL
EDUCATIONAL BASED ON THIRD PARTY
ALLEGATIONS.
AND WE SEE THIS BILL AS SIX
DURING THIS PERIOD ALL THE WAY
UP TO FIVE YEARS WERE SOMEONE
COULD.
LOSE THEIR RIGHTS -- WITHOUT.
EVER HAVING THAT CRIMINAL
CONVICTION MIDDLE EDUCATIONAL
TALK ABOUT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
HERE -- FOR TO REVEAL THE THE
BUILD LACKS REAL CLEAR GUIDANCE
ON WIN A FIVE YEAR ORDER WILL GO
INTO A FACT THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY LONG TIME. TO DO THAT
AND AS WELL AS THE BURDEN IS ON
THE PERSON. TO TO APPEAL THOSE --
EACH YEAR.
BEGIN A NEGATIVE CAN BE A VERY
CHALLENGING THING AND SO -- WE
THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES WITH THIS
BILL -- WE UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
IS GOOD BEHIND THE BILL -- BUT
WE JUST HAVE THOSE THOSE ISSUES
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
WHAT THAT WERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING KNOWN ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES.
HER RIGHT IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A SEVEN
MEMBER DO YOU WANT TO IT I I I I
DO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE FIVE
YEARS IS IN CASES.
LIKE THE THE PERSON HAS DEMENTIA
YEAH I MEAN IN IN THAT CASE YOU
DON'T REALLY NEED TO REVIEW
EVERY YEAR BUT AS MENTIONED
THERE IS THE TO THE ABILITY TO
GO BACK TO COURT EVERY YEAR --
TO TO GET BACK THE ABILITY TO A
POSSESS.
GOD.
AND WITH THAT.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A
VERY EXCELLENT -- WE HAVE A
MOTION LET'S TO A ROLL CALL THE
MOTION IS THE BILL AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER BY INNER HI MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE.
I WILL HAVE THE BILL AND CALL.
AND YOU CAN GO TO YOUR NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS ITEM SEVEN AB.
THREE THREE NINE THIS IS --
ALONG THE SAME THEME OF
STRENGTHENING THE ARE OF A TOOL
OF GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS AB THREE THREE NINE WILL
REQUIRE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE POLICIES.
AND STANDARDS RELATING TO TV ARE
OWES IT WOULD PROVIDE A
JUMPSTART BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
SAYS LAW ENFORCEMENT AWARENESS
OF THIS TOOL BY REQUIRING LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS TO WORK WITH GUN
VIOLENCE UP PREVENTION EXPERTS.
THE PUBLIC AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO DEVELOP THESE
POLICIES AND STANDARDS -- THIS
THIS PART PROCESS WILL RESULT IN --
THE COMMAND STAFF THE PATROL
OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC
ACQUIRING THE KNOWLEDGE NEEDED
TO USE GDR ROSEN BE PROACTIVE IN
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTIES
OF SANTA CRUZ LOS ANGELES
INVENTOR ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF AMANDA WILCOX FOR THE
BRADY UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
RAINY PERIOD THERE RE DISSOCIATE
SOME HAVE A POOR I CAN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE RATE SEEN NINE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S CALM ANSWER QUESTIONS BY
MY COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
WE'LL GO -- I JUST WANNA MAKE
ONE SLIGHT -- APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING THIS BILL AND I THINK --
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT?
THE LAWS WAS FIRST PUT INTO
PLACE.
IS A VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL -- TO
ASSIST -- THOSE CLOSE TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE -- KNOWN TO BE MAKING
THREATS OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. TO
TEMPORARILY REMOVE WEAPONS BUT
AND WE'VE SEEN -- IT WAS LOW
UPTAKE IN THE INITIAL YEARS
AFTER THE BILL WAS PASSED BUT
THERE'S BEEN INCREASING BUT
WE'VE ALSO FOUND THAT -- THERE'S
A LOT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT IS
NOT AWARE OF THE TOOL AND IF WE
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE INCIDENT
THAT INSPIRED THE TOOL WHICH WAS
THE ISLA VISTA SHOOTING.
THE MOTHER OF THAT SHOOTER WAS
QUITE AWARE OF THE THREATS THAT
THAT SHOOTER WAS MAKING.
AND I SAW HIS POST THAT HE WAS
ABOUT TO GO OUT AND DO A
SHOOTING AND HAD -- ENLISTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A TOOL AVAILABLE SO THE MORE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS WHERE
THE MORE -- MOTHERS LIKE THE
INDIVIDUAL IN THIS CASE WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE SERVED BECAUSE WHEN
THEY CONTACT LAW ENFORCEMENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN SUGGESTS THAT
THERE SUCH A TOOL AVAILABLE SO
REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR BRINGING -- THIS BILL WHICH
HELPS M. ACHIEVE THAT.
AND WE'VE GOT A MOTION -- I TO
CURE OF VALUE TO PREVIOUS SAYS
THE CLOTHES THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S DO AND THIS
ONE IS MOVED -- AND THE BILL AS
BEFORE US [inaudible] TO
APPROPRIATIONS OKAY ROLL CALL
INNER HI IN OUR AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MORALE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
LET'S GO TO ITEM.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX FORTY FIVE
SB SIX FORTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
POSTING OF THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE ON EXISTING
LABELS ON GUN PACKAGING.
ON THE FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATION EXAM AND ON NEW
SIGNS AND GUN SHOPS.
THERE'S BEEN A STARTLING
INCREASE OF FIREARMS SUICIDES IN
CALIFORNIA AND CURRENTLY THERE
IS NO MANDATED INFORMATION ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION RESOURCES AT
ANY POINT DURING THE PROCESS OF
ATTAINING A FIREARM.
THIS GAP WAS HIGHLIGHTED TO ME
BY A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN
VENTURA COUNTY WHO LOST HIS
BROTHER TO A FIREARM SUICIDE.
AND I AM PROUD TO BE OFFERING
HIS LEGISLATIVE IDEA.
AB SIX FOUR FIVE RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND IT IS MY HOPE THAT
THE BILL WILL PROVIDE GREATER
ACCESS TO INFORMATION THAT
CONSISTS AN INDIVIDUAL IN CRISIS.
THANK YOU.
BUT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ELIZABETH THAT'S BEEN US ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA I WOULD JUST NOT VERY
QUICKLY BETWEEN THE YEARS OF TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN NEARLY. TWO THIRDS OF
THE A GUN RELATED DEATHS
INVENTOR COUNTY WERE I'D DO TO
SUICIDE AND SUBURBAN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR OF
BETSEY ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION ARCHER SUPPORT.
CATTY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE CAPPING LUNCH
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
CERTAINLY NOT AN OPPOSITION TO
THE POLICY AND THE GOALS.
AND IN FACT TO THE AMERICAN
FOUNDATION OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION.
HAVE EMBARKED ON A A NATIONWIDE
PROGRAM IN THIS AREA IN THAT.
THEY HAVE AVAILABLE. FOR THE
SAME THINGS THAT ARE BEIN
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL AND I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THERE WAS
LEGISLATION ON THIS BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE JUST
CHANGE THE WARNING LABELS FOR
INSERT IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT INTERSTATE
COMMERCE SO THE CHANGEOVER IS
PROBLEMATIC JUST FOR A SENTENCE.
AND IT'S ALREADY A VERY LONG
CUMBERSOME -- ISSUE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FOUNDATION
THEY POINT OUT THAT YOU HATE IT
IT SENDS THE WRONG SIGNAL WE
HAVE VETERANS WHO WERE ARE PART
OF THE TEAM EVALUATING THIS
PROGRAM.
IS THAT IT'S IT A POSTER.
AND STICKERS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT ARE FINE BUT IT SENDS THE
WRONG MESSAGE WHAT.
THE EFF CELLS IN THE RETAILER'S
REALLY NEED IS TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE WARNING SIGNS OF
SUICIDE.
AND SO THEY'VE EMBARKED UPON A
WHOLE TRAINING CAMPAIGN THEY
HAVE VIDEOS THEY HAVE TRAINING
TOOLS THEY HAVE.
EARLY WARNING SIGNS OF WORKING
WITH THE MEDICAL PROFESSION SO
WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
AYE I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT THAT YOU FIND A WAY TO
SORT OF BLEND.
BECAUSE ACTUALLY -- WHERE
RETAILERS ARE ALREADY GETTING
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION?
IF WE COULD -- IF THEY'RE
ALREADY PROVIDING IT THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS WITH THE
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
THEN THAT -- ENCOMPASSES IT WE
WOULD ALSO ASKS FOR SOME KIND OF
FEES IN ON THE WARNING LABEL SO
THE INVENTORY CAN BE DEALT WITH
IF.
THE WARNING PART GOES FORWARD SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR BUT WE HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT ACTUALLY DOES MORE THAN
THIS AND SO -- WE'RE VERY
PLEASED ABOUT THAT AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE I HAVE PROVIDED
THE COMMITTEE.
ON A WITH THAT INFORMATION AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR WORK ON IT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NONE -- AGAIN
COMMON SIR.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE I LIVE JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT -- CURRENTLY I'VE REPEAT
WHAT I SAID ALREADY THERE'S NO.
UPDATED INFORMATION AVAILABLE AT
ANY POINT -- IN THE PROCESS OF
OBTAINING A FIRE ARM WHEN I
TALKED TO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHOSE BROTHER OFFICER
WHO WHOSE BROTHER WAS A VETERAN.
HE SAID THAT IF AT ANY POINT
DURING THIS.
CRISIS IF HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE -- TO CALL SOMEBODY AND GET
SOME HELP THAT -- IT BUT THERE
WAS THE POTENTIAL THAT THIS
SUICIDE WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
AND ON YES THIS IS NOT THE
COMPLETE ANSWER TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF CRISIS THAT WERE IN.
BUT IF IT IS EFFECTIVE IN
PREVENTING A SMALL NUMBER OF
SUICIDES I THINK THAT -- IT
DEFINITELY IS WORTH IT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND I DO WANT TO HAVE TO ADD.
ADD ONE OTHER THING WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS FOR NEW SIGNS AND IT IS
PRINTING THE WARNING ON EXISTING
LABELS.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO THE MOTION IS -- TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS -- LET'S
DO A ROLL CALL.
SKINNER HI I'M MORE LACKEY
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
AYE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MORALE.
WIENER I MEAN HI.
BY TWO WILL HAVE THE BILL ON
CALL AND THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO TO OUR
NEXT -- WHAT WE'VE DONE YOURS
WILL GO TO OUR NEXT ITEM I THINK
WE HAVE A [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OPAL IS LEAVING.
SEE HOW IT IS -- I'M SORRY I'D
LIKE BY [inaudible]
PROPEL GREAT -- THIS IS ITEM
EIGHT AB.
THREE NINETY ONE YES YOU MAY
PROCEED BETTER CHAIR YOU.
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
TO YOU AB THREE NINETY ONE THAT
ENABLES VEHICLE RENTAL COMPANIES
TO REPORT THEFT AS VEHICLES
BECOME OVER DO.
RATHER THAN BEING REQUIRED TO
WAIT FIVE DAYS AFTER THE VEHICLE
RETURN.
VEHICLE THEFT IS UNIQUE IN A
SENSE AT ANY WASTED TIME IN THE
REPORTING PROCESS ALLOWS THE
CRIMINAL TO GEOGRAPHICALLY.
FROM THE SEA.
MOTIVATION FOR AUTOMOBILE THEFT
IS HIGHER WHEN THERE IS A FIVE
DAY GRACE.
PERIOD GIVEN LEAVING PLENTY OF
TIME TO FLEE THE SCENE AND
DISMEMBER THE VEHICLE FOR THE
SALE.
WHEN FRAUD IS DISCOVERED IS
IMPORTANT AT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS NOTIFIED IMMEDIATELY RATHER
THAT WAITING UNTIL THE FIVE DAYS
EXPIRE AFTER EXPIRATION OF THE
RENTAL CAR LEASE?
I AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE OF
MAMMOTHS AND APPRECIATE THEM
GREATLY.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THE FIVE DAY
WAITING PERIOD WILL BE MINIMIZED
SEVENTY TWO HOURS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT PROPER PROCEDURES
ARE CONDUCTED TO ENSURE BOTH
SAFETY AND UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN
THE RENTAL CAR AGENCY IN A
RENTER OF THE VEHICLE.
COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT SIMPLY
EXPEDITES IT IMPROVES THE SYSTEM
OF TRACKING DOWN STOLEN CARS.
BY LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS OKAY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
IS [inaudible]
FOR SIX OF MARCOS.
ASSOCIATION -- WE OPPOSE AB --
THREE NINETY ONE I UNDERSTAND
JUST FROM HEARING THE AUTHOR
SPEAK THAT THERE'S A AN
AMENDMENT THAT HE'S ACCEPTING
AND IT'S GOING TO CHANGE THE
TIME AND SO THE RIGHT AND THE
COMMITTEE -- REQUESTED AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD ALIGN THE
BILL WITH THE CURRENT STATUTE A
BILL BY A FORM OF FORMER BILL
THAT'S NOW IN STATUTE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING WHICH
ALLOWS.
THE RENTAL CAR ENTITY TO IN
EFFECT REMOTELY TURN ON THE GPS
OF THE VEHICLE WITHIN SEVENTY
TWO HOURS SO SINCE THAT'S
ALREADY INTO A FACT -- WITHOUT
IT THIS BILL OR NOT WE JUST
ALIGNED IT WITH THAT STATUTE.
AND WITH THIS BILL -- STILL
REDUCE THE TIME PERIOD FROM FIVE
DAYS TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS THE
SEVENTY TWO HOURS TO THE SEVEN
TWO EXACTLY THE SAME AS WHEN.
THE RENTAL AGENCY CAN REMOTELY --
AN INITIATE THE GPS AT WITH IT
ALSO BE THAT WOULD BE THE TIME
PERIOD WITHIN WHICH THEY WOULD
REPORT IT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
THE WOULD THAT STILL BE FORTY
EIGHT HOURS NO. SIX SEVENTY TWO
HOURS THEY COULD NOT REPORT TILL
AFTER SEVENTY TWO HOURS WE
WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENT YES MA'AM.
ARE RIGHT THIS IS A GOOD NEWS WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION -- DO WE HAVE --
OKAY WE'VE GOT A MOTION.
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SOME
REMEMBER EXACTLY REQUESTED AN
AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT -- SEEING NO
DISCUSSION THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED.
TO YES SENATOR TAXI I THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THAT AMENDMENTS
CASSETTE CONCERN ME AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THERE'S A
BALANCING THAT NEEDS TO GO ON
HERE THERE'S A PRIVACY ISSUE.
AND I THINK SEVENTY TWO HOURS IS
AN APPROPRIATE LENGTH OF TIME
BUT I THINK WITH ALL OF THESE
KINDS OF MEASURES WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE.
AND NOT ALLOW THE THUMB ON THE
SCALE OF BALANCE.
TO BE MOVED SO I THINK THIS BILL
DOES SAID AND I'M I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AND AND MOVE THE BILL AS
WELL.
THANK.
THURMOND SORRY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO A PROBES
LET'S DO ROLL CALL.
INNER BY IN OUR AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MORALE.
WIENER.
BILLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WILL NOW GO
TO LET'S SEE WHO'S HERE NOEL
AUTHORS.
YES LET'S TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALRIGHT LET'S DO ROLL CALL.
YEAH HI IN OUR AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL MOREAU WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT THE CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT.
ARE ON CALL EXCUSE ME.
SINCE WE HAVE ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL WAIT TILL THEY COME BACK
AND WILL RE OPEN THE ROLE AND
EVERYTHING.
LET ME ANNOUNCE ALSO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A HARD STOP AT ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE WHERE WILL EITHER CONCLUDE
THE COMMITTEE ORG.
IF WE HAVE NOT HEARD ALL THE
BILLS WILL DO A RECESS -- END OF
HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE COMPLETED
THE BILLS BUT IF WE HAVEN'T WE
WILL RESUME AFTER CAUCUS --
WE'RE WAITING AUTHORS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO GET YOUR
BILLS HEARD QUICKLY.
GET TO PUBLIC SAFETY
[inaudible]
WHAT ROOM?
ROOM
[inaudible]
FORTY TWO OH THREE YEAH.
THE REMEMBER WHEN SURPRISE GET
UP TO THE MIKE WHAT'S YOUR YES.
RIGHT THERE ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS
WE'VE GOT ITEM OF A NINETEEN AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE GRAND ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO
WILL HEAR BOTH A AHEAD THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
FELLOW.
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE HERE
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONCE A
DECISION TO MAKE A A IS MADE TO
TRANSFER A JUVENILE TO ADULT
COURT.
THEY MAY NOT BE REFERRED BACK TO
THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
AND THIS CREATES SOME UNFAIR
SITUATIONS AS WE LEARN MORE
DYNAMICS OF THE CASE.
THIS BILL BASICALLY -- PROVIDES
A NARROWLY TAILORED REMEDY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE BY
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS FOR
JUVENILE TO REQUEST THE CRIMINAL
COURT TO TRANSFER CASE TO
JUVENILE COURT IN A LIMITED
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS.
WHERE THE BASIS FOR THE RITUAL
TRANSFERS LATER DETERMINED TO BE
INVALID?
I THINK THIS IS A MUCH NEEDED
MECHANISM TO ENSURE FAIRNESS AND
ALLOW USED TO RECEIVE THE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THE
SERVICES THEY NEED TO
REHABILITATE.
THEMSELVES IN THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TODAY WILL REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
DEFENDER CENTER AND THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I WILL LET MY WITNESSES SELF
INTRODUCE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE -- WITNESSES YOU MAY
PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SUPER
RAIL ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
ADDRESSES A GAP IN OUR LAWS THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED IN COURT OF
APPEAL CASE CALLED PEOPLE VERSUS
SELF.
IT WON'T AFFECT A LOT OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BUT FOR THOSE THAT IT
DOES AFFECT IT WILL BE LIFE
CHANGING.
IT ADDRESSES THE SITUATION WHEN
THE PROMISE FOR ON WHICH A YOUNG
PERSON WAS TRANSFERRED TO THE
ADULT COURT.
TURNS OUT NOT TO BE TRUE IN
TERMS OF THE NATURE OF THE
OFFENSE.
USUALLY WHEN JUVENILE COURTS
CONSIDER A TRANSFER DECISION
THEY'RE WORKING FROM THE ARREST
REPORT THAT WAS PREPARED SHORTLY
AFTER THE INCIDENT OCCURRED.
AND OFTEN TIMES WHEN -- IT TURNS
OUT NOT TO BE ACCURATE OR NOT
FULLY ACCURATE ONCE THE CASES
BEEN FULLY INVESTIGATED BUT THAT
ISN'T DISCOVERED UNTIL THE CASES
IN ADULT COURT.
SO -- A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE PROVIDES A THREE TIERED
PROCESS FOR CERTAIN OF THE CASES
WHERE THIS IS OCCURRED TO GO
BACK TO JUVENILE COURT FOR
DISPOSITION.
ON IT HAS A ONE TIER IS FOR
CASES WHICH IN WHICH THE CHILD
IS FOUND GUILTY AT TRIAL OF ONLY
A MISDEMEANOR IN ADULT COURT.
AND AND THOSE ARE CASES WHERE
THE WHERE THE YOUNG PERSON
WOULDN'T HAVE EVEN BEEN ELIGIBLE
FOR TRANSFER IF THAT'D BEEN
KNOWN AT THE BEGINNING.
THERE'S A SECOND TIER FOUR CASES
WHERE YOUTH ARE TRIED IT OUT
TRIED IN THE ADULT COURT AND
FOUND GUILTY.
OF A LESS SERIOUS FELONY OR A
MISDEMEANOR INSTEAD OF THE VERY
SERIOUS OFFENCE SEVEN OH SEVEN
BE OFFENSE THEY WERE CHARGED
WITH.
ON AND THEN THE THIRD TIER AND
THIS WILL BE MOST OF THE CASES
CASES THAT ARE DISPOSED OF IN
ADULT COURT BY PLEA BARGAIN --
WITH THE PROSECUTOR.
IF THE PROSECUTOR AGREES THAT
THE CASE CAN GO BACK TO JUVENILE
COURT -- AND THE COURT EXERCISES
ITS DISCRETION TO SEND THE CASE
BACK THOSE CASES MAY BE SENT
BACK TO JUVENILE COURT.
THIS WHOLE BILL AFFECTS A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF YOUTH THERE ARE
ONLY A HUNDRED NINETEEN CASES
DISPOSED OF IN THE ADULT SYSTEM
LAST YEAR OR FOR THE BIKE AND
GET THE COULD SIT FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE MOST RECENT DATA.
AND OF THOSE ONLY A FEW YOUNG
PEOPLE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE UNDER
THIS BILL.
BUT FOR THOSE WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE IT WOULD MAKE AN
ENORMOUS DIFFERENCE BOTH TO THAT
YOUNG PERSON AND TO THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
AND ARTHUR BUT WE WILL TALK
ABOUT WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
X. WITNESS.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING MADAM
SECRETARY AT I'M SORRY. TO THAT
EVERY TIME.
RENDON CHEVRON AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ART THE BOISE -- AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROUD TO SPUR COSPONSORED IS
VERY NECESSARY A LEGISLATION
ARJUN AYE VOTE.
ON THE BILL.
BUT JUST TO ADD TO WHAT'S
ALREADY HAVE BEEN SAID -- AN
OFFER HERE TODAY ON A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE WE LIKE TO
CONSIDER -- THE SHORT AND LONG
TERM BENEFIT TO MINORS THAT ARE
TARGETED BY THE BILL AND TO THE
COMMUNITIES FROM WHICH THEY COME
FROM AND THE TO THE LARGEST --
CHILDREN RETURNING BACK TO
JUVENILE COURT.
COURT JURISDICTION WILL RECEIVE
TREATMENT AND REHABILITATION
SERVICES THAT THEY THAT THEY IN
MOST CASES FOR NOT RECEIVE IN A
COURT OF CRIMINAL JURISDICTION --
THESE MINERS WILL BE.
HELD ACCOUNTABLE -- HOWEVER WITH
REAL BILL ATTENTION AS THE GOAL
AS OPPOSED TO SIMPLY PUNISHMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
QUALIFYING OFFENSES AS AS MISS
PEARL POINTED OUT.
BOB THE REFERRAL BACK TO
JUVENILE COURT THESE NINE SERIES
NON VIOLENT FELONY OFFENSES
MISDEMEANORS -- APPOINT
SATISFACTORY COMPLETION OF
APPEAR TO PROBATION IN THESE
CASES THESE MINERS WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE RECORDS
IMMEDIATELY SEALED HICH WILL
BENEFIT THE MEMBERS SO
EMPLOYMENT.
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
HOUSING JUST TO NAME A FEW OF
BENEFITS OF THAT AND TO AVOID
MANY OF THE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES OF A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION.
WELL -- WHICH IS GOOD FOR THE
MINOR AND THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
MORAL MORE OVER THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS A MUCH BETTER
IN A MUCH BETTER POSITION TO
WORK WITH MINORS EVEN THOSE THAT
ARE AT THE END OF THEIR TEENAGE
YEARS.
MORE SO THAN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE THOSE -- SAY
AGAIN THANK TO TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE HARD WORK TO SPENT ON ON
THIS BILL AND WE ARE CHEN I'D
VOTE ON A ON A BE.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE BUT OUR
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AT THE SHORE ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
IRVING OUR AS YOU THE JUSTICE
COALITION HIGHLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
CAN I GIVE ME JUST AS COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
BETTY I HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IN SUPPORT OKAY PLEASE ONLY WITH
WHITE J. C. IN SUPPORT.
THE DEVIL'S Y. D. SAN SUPPORT.
BRIDGET WITH THE ACLU SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
BY ANY OTHERS OKAY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER OKAY LET'S GO.
DANIEL DAVENPORT CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILIES UNITED IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DANTE OUR REGION ON BLACK LAWS
MATTERS.
AND ALSO -- Y. J. C. HOME
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
RIGHT SIR -- CENSORED ALREADY
CALLED WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
DON'T SEE ANYONE COMING TO THE
TABLE -- LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES.
SENATE JACKSON YEAH I'M I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO DO
REFORM ON OUR SYSTEM I JUST HOPE
THAT WE INVEST THE RESOURCES WE
NEED TO TO MAKE THESE PROGRAMS
WORK.
AS WE MOVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE AWAY
FROM EXCUSE ME JUVENILE JUSTICE
INTO A NEW DEPARTMENT -- TRYING
TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES OF
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS FOR
REHABILITATION ALL THE THINGS
THAT I THINK.
MANY OF US TO VOTE FOR THESE
BILLS WANT TO SEE HAPPEN.
BUT WITHOUT THE RESOURCES IT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN SO --
INVESTING IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE KNOW ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO HELP OUR
USE.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THEM OUT THERE
WE'RE GOING TO FIND THAT THESE
EFFORTS WERE MAKING TO REALLY
GIVE THEM A SECOND CHANCE.
THE PUBLIC HAS SPOKEN STAND FORD
IF IF WE IF WE DON'T SEE RESULTS
SO I APPRECIATE THIS BILL I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE IT I JUST THINK WE
HAVE TO BE COGNIZANT OF MAKING
PROMISES AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO KEEP THEM.
SO A THANK YOU FOR THIS AND AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
MADAM CHAIR.
RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE EXCELLENT LET'S TAKE A
ROLL CALL IN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER BY IN OUR AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
AT FIRST I JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
BOOK KEEP THE BILL ON CALL AND
WE CAN GO TO OUR NEXT ITEM WHICH
IS ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B..
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO AGAIN -- AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
TWO WILLOW COURTS REQUIRE AN
ALTERNATIVE COMMUNITY SERVICE
OPTION OTHER THAN LITTER PICK UP
IN A PERSONS CONVICTED LITTERING.
AND A BODY OF WATER AND THE
INTENT OF THIS BILLS PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY AMONG COURTS.
AND TAKEN TO A CONSIDERATION
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES BASED ON THE
COMMUNITIES NEEDS IT HAS
RECEIVED RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
RIGHT ANY -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
COLLEAGUES. TO HAVE A MOTION.
NO QUESTIONS.
WELL.
YEAH GO AHEAD SENATOR JACKSON'S
STUFF HERE THIS IS -- I
RECOGNIZE TONIGHT LIKE SUPPORT
THIS TO THE EXTENT I'M NOT.
DESPERATELY OPPOSED TO THE
NOTION BUT I KNOW THAT WHEN
WE'VE HAD -- A PEOPLE WHO --
COMMIT.
A PARTICULAR TYPE OF OFFENSE.
DAD WHEN THEY ARE REQUIRED AS A
CONDITION OF PROBATION TO DIVE
RIGHT INTO.
THE IMPACTS OF THAT BEHAVIOR --
IT TENDS TO MAKE A VERY STRONG
STATEMENT TO AN IMPRESSION ON
THEM I THINK OF GRAFFITI.
WHEN YOU HAVE USE HAVING TO
CLEAN UP THE GRAFFITI THEY'VE
CREATED THEY REALIZE HER
DIRECTLY THE SIGNIFICANCE AND A
TAD SO -- I CAN -- I KNOW THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE IS -- IS --
IMPORTANT TO TO KIND OF GET
PEOPLE TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS
OF THEIR BEHAVIOR -- AND IN
SUPPORT THIS I JUST THINK THAT.
MAKING THE PUNISHMENT IF YOU
WILL.
RELEVANT TO THE THE ACTUAL
ACTION WHICH RESULTS IN THE
PROBATIONARY IMPOSITION IS IS
VERY VERY HELPFUL SO -- I KNOW
THAT THERE AREN'T ALWAYS
EXAMPLES WHERE WE CAN DO THIS
BUT I JUST THINK.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT IF WE WANT TO HAVE THE
IMPACTS WERE LOOKING FOR SURE
AND AND I AGREE WITH THAT AND I
THINK WHAT THIS THE GOAL THIS
BILLS TO PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES
FOR INSTANCE OF SOMEONE.
LEADERS -- BUT THERE DISABLED IN
THE PHYSICALLY HAVE CHALLENGES
IT GIVES THE JUDGE SOME
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS -- TO TO
WORK WITH.
PART WE HAVE A MOTION.
DO YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT
FAST RIVA OKAY LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL THIS MOTION IS.
JUST TO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE.
THE BILL WILL BE ON CALL SINCE
WE ARE MISSING MEMBER.
AND WE WILL GO NOW TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
TWO AB.
SIXTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
[inaudible] SIXTY ONE AB.
SIXTY ONE AB SIXTY ONE ITEM.
TO HE MAY PERCENT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FIRST IMAGES THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND CAN I START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO SET THE BILL TO NOT START
TILL SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TO GIVE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TIME TO FOLLOW THEIR PROCEDURAL
CALENDARS -- AS YOU KNOW AB
SIXTY ONE EXPAND YOUR PREVIOUS
LAW MADAM CHAIR WHICH IS TO
EXPAND.
THE PEOPLE WHO CAN USE A GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER --
CURRENTLY ONLY -- FAMILY MEMBERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN USE A
GUN BONTA STRAINING ORDER WERE
PROPOSING TO EXPAND IT TO
EMPLOYERS COWORKERS EMPLOYEES OF
A HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE -- AND
WE TIGHTENED THE BILL IN
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY SO THAT
THERE'S A SET -- CODIFICATION
AROUND HOW MUCH INTERACTION THE
INDIVIDUALS I HAD BEFORE THE
ISSUE A GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS.
AS YOU KNOW -- EVERYBODY HAS A
RIGHT TO GO TO SCHOOL AND TO
WORK WITHOUT FEARING FOR THEIR
LIFE WE THINK THIS IS A TOOL.
THAT THOSE FOLKS CAN USE IN
THESE TYPES OF SITUATIONS AND
UNFORTUNATELY SEEN WAY TOO MANY
MASS SHOOTINGS OCCUR IN
WORKPLACES AS WELL AS SCHOOLS.
SO WITH THAT WERE RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE ON A. B..
SIXTY ONE RIGHT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CALVIN CREEK ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA STUDENT ACTIVISTS -- WERE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND SO I THINK
MY FIRST POINT IS THAT.
COM I PERSONALLY KNOW AS A
STUDENT THAT MANY PEOPLE SEE
THEIR TEACHERS OR OTHERWISE
THEIR CO WORKERS THEIR EMPLOYER.
A LOT MORE SOMETIMES THAN THE TO
THEIR FAMILY ESPECIALLY IF THEY
HAVE A DIFFICULT SITUATION.
AT HOME AND SO THOSE PEOPLE
SOMETIMES NO BETTER THAN A
FAMILY WHEN THAT PERSON IS AT
RISK WHEN THEY CAN FEEL
THREATENED WHEN THEY'RE ACTING
ERRATICALLY FOR EXAMPLE -- AND
IS ONE EXAMPLE OF COURSE -- I
BRING THIS UP EVERY TIME WE TALK
ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT AT THE
PARKING SHOOTING FRIENDS AND
TEACHERS KNEW THE SHOOTER HAD AN
OBSESSION WITH GUNS.
THAT THE SHOOTER HELD RACIST
HOMOPHOBIC ANTI SEMITIC AND
XENOPHOBIC VIEWS.
AND HAD EVEN STATED.
BEFORE THE ATTACK I AM GOING TO
BE A PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL FUTURE.
AND SO LAW ENFORCEMENT FAILED TO
ACT TO MOVE HIS GUNS THE FROM
HIS POSSESSION.
AND YET -- IF HIS TEACHERS WHO
KNEW HIM HAD BEEN ABLE TO
PETITION THE COURT. FOR HIS GUNS
BECAUSE THIS CREATED THAT
TRAGEDY MIGHT HAVE BEEN AVERTED.
AND I THINK IT'S ALSO BEEN THE
THERE ARE OTHER EXAMPLES THE
SHOOTING EARLIER THIS YEAR IN
AURORA.
ILLINOIS IS ANOTHER ONE WHERE
BACKGROUND CHECKS FAILED AND
THAN EMPLOYEE WHO HAD JUST BEEN
DISMISSED -- PULLED OUT A GUN IN
HIS WORKPLACE.
AND SHOT FIVE PEOPLE.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT OVER FIVE HUNDRED
WORKPLACE HOMICIDES OCCUR EVERY
YEAR AND FIREARMS ARE USED IN
80%.
OF THOSE CASES.
AND THAT MIGHT MY SECOND POINT
IS THAT [inaudible]
PHONE.
HELLO THE BIGGEST CAUSE OF GUN
BY OF GUN DEATHS IN THIS -- IN
THIS COUNTRY IS SUICIDE OVER TWO
THIRDS OF ALL COME WITH A TO
DEATH ARE SUICIDES -- WITH OVER
THOUSANDS OF THOSE BY CHILDREN
AND TEENS EVERY YEAR.
AND WHILE WELL OVER 90% OF
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS ARE
UNSUCCESSFUL WHEN THE MEASURE
THAT DOES NOT INVOLVE A FIREARM.
85% OF SUICIDES ATTEMPTS USING A
FIREARM RESULT IN DEATH.
GUNS FACILITATE SUICIDE AND IT
STANDS TO REASON THEN THAT IT HE
WAY TO PREVENT SUICIDES IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT A SUICIDAL PERSON
DOES NOT HAVE A GUN.
AT THEIR DISPOSAL SUICIDAL
PEOPLE NEEDED HELP.
NEED HELP TO FEEL THAT THEY HAVE
A PURPOSE IN THE WORLD THEY NEED
THEIR FAMILY THEIR CO WORKERS
THE TEACHERS TO SPEAK UP AND TO
ACTIVELY GET INVOLVED.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THEIR LIVES
[inaudible]
AND SO.
AGAIN WHILE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE
CONTINUE.
TO WORK ON IMPLEMENTING THE DVR --
BELL -- IT'S BEEN UNEVEN SO FAR
THERE ARE OTHER BILLS TO ADDRESS
THAT BUT WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT EMPLOYERS CO
WORKERS AND TEACHERS PEOPLE TO
ACT DIRECTLY AND GO DIRECTLY TO
A COURT. TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
OF THEIR SCHOOLS THEIR WORK
PLACES AND THEIR STUDENTS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND ALSO -- EXPECT I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT OF I'M
AND WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
UNITED FOR AGAINST -- GUNBOATS.
RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THINK THEY'RE SOME OF THE MIKE
THERE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA WHICH YOU ARE WELL AWARE
WAS THE SIDE OF THE BORDER LINE
SHOOTING LAST NOVEMBER.
A TRAGIC EVENT THE REALLY
SHATTER THE COMMUNITY AND THE
BOARD IS LOOKING TO SUPPORT WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN KEEP FIREARMS.
OUT OF THE HANDS OF THOSE WHO
ARE COULD BE AT RISK OF HARMING
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS WE THINK
MISTER TING FOR THIS BILL.
HI KATHY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL KENDALL
BECAUSE OUR BEHALF OF THE
GIFFORDS LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BRIDGET SIR RALLY ON BEHALF OF
RISING SCHOLARS AT CAL STATE
LONG BEACH IN SUPPORT.
PART OF THEIR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL HAVE TO AT THE TABLE IN
THE OTHERS CAN BE AT THE MIKE.
AND THERE'S TWO SPOTS RIGHT
THERE [inaudible]
RED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA.
AB SIXTY ONE SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDS THE CLASS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE AUTHORIZED TO SEEK EX PARTE
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
AND WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
THIS WILL MAKE THE SYSTEM PRONE
TO ABUSE.
THE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THAT IF A
CO WORKERS PETITIONING FOR A G.
B. RO THEY MUST HAVE HAD
SUBSTANTIAL INTERACTIONS WITH
THE PERSON THEY MUST HAVE THE
APPROVAL OF THE EMPLOYER.
BUT THIS DOES LITTLE TO PREVENT
SOMEONE FROM ACTING OUT OF
IRRATIONAL FEARS OR BIASED DUE
TO A CO WORKERS RACE OR RELIGION
OR NATURAL NATIONAL ORIGIN OR
FROM RETALIATION.
BECAUSE JUST AS THE CO WORKER
MIGHT BE ACTING OUT OF BIAS AN
EMPLOYER MIGHT WORK SIGN OFF ON
SUCH A REQUEST OUT OF BIAS --
THE BILL ALSO AS AMENDED ALSO
REQUIRES THAT IF A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE IS PETITIONING FOR A G.
B. R. O. THEY OBTAIN APPROVAL OF
THIS SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION. FOR
SIMILAR REASONS THIS DOES LITTLE
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERN THE
PETITIONS WILL BE FILED IN A
DISCRIMINATORY MANNER.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROJECT
RATIONALE FOR AN EX PARTE ORDER
IS THE ALLEGED URGENCY OF THE
THREAT YET THIS BILL ALLOWS A
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE TO SEEK AN EX
PARTE ORDER EVEN IF THEY HAVEN'T
SEEN THE STUDENT FOR SIX MONTHS.
THIS TIME FRAME IS INCONSISTENT
WITH THE SUPPOSED URGENCY OF THE
ORDER.
WHEN SOMEONE IS SUBJECT TO AN EX
PARTE ORDER THEY DO NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
OR PRESENT THEIR SIDE BEFORE THE
ORDER IS CRACKED CARRIED OUT?
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT A G.
B. R. O. HAS BEEN APPROVED UNTIL
AN OFFICER SHOWS UP AT THEIR
DOOR AND ORDERS THEM TO
SURRENDER THEIR FIREARMS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ACCUSED OF MAKING CRIMINAL
THREATS OR COMMITTING ANY CRIME
WHATSOEVER THEY MAY NOT EVEN
HAVE FIREARMS.
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF AN
OFFICER SHOWING UP IN A PERSONS
HOME EXPECTING TO FIND SOMEONE
WHO IS ARMED AND DANGEROUS EVEN
WHEN IN FACT THEY ARE NEITHER.
FINALLY AS GOVERNOR BROWN NOTED
IN HIS VETO MESSAGE OF THE SAME
BILL LAST YEAR.
EVERYONE IN THIS BILL CAN
ALREADY SEEK EX PARTE ORDERS BY
WORKING WITH THE POLICE OR THE
FAMILY OF THE INDIVIDUALS I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT.
MORE CALIFORNIA TOO OLD HAVE
APPLIED IN THE PARKLAND SHOOTING --
THE TEACHERS AND STUDENTS WHO
ARE CONCERNED COULD HAVE GONE TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ASKED FOR
THEM -- TO GET TV RO -- IN THAT
CASE.
PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE IS OF
COURSE OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE BUT
WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR EFFORTS
TO DO THIS DO NOT ON
UNNECESSARILY COMPROMISED CIVIL
LIBERTIES -- UNFORTUNATELY AB
SIXTY ONE FAILS TO ACHIEVE THIS
BALANCE AND FOR THIS REASON WE
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THE RECORD AND
WE WOULD NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE ACLU -- SHE DROVE BY MOST OF
THE POINTS HOME AND I JUST WANT.
TO REITERATE THAT GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS OR SHOULD BE
INTO PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME OR JUDICATA
MENTALLY ILL THESE ARE BASED ON
THIRD PARTY ALLEGATIONS.
AND THIS BILL'S GOING TO EXPAND
THAT THE CLASS OF PEOPLE THEY
CAN BRING THESE AND OURS WAS
COMMENTED EARLIER THIS CAN
ALREADY BE DONE THROUGH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT THIS TIME.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE GE AROSE DO
NOT ADDRESS ANY OTHER ELEMENT OF
DANGEROUS NYSSA PERSON -- MAY
POSE IN IT DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY
MENTAL HEALTH ASSISTANCE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY BE FOCUSING ON FOR THAT
MANY OTHER REASONS WERE STAND IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR ROY GRIFFIS BEGIN
I'LL BE UP THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION WEREN'T
STRONG OPPOSITION ALSO THIRTY
TWO YEARS RETIRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE'S NO BETTER
NON BIASED GATEKEEPER THAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
AND NO BETTER PEOPLE THAN
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS TO KNOW
THESE PEOPLE'S NEEDS SO WE STAND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MANAGER.
MANAGER MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUNNELS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MANY HIGHER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
THE ACLU AND ALSO -- I'M SORRY
BUT YOUR ORGANIZATION'S NAME.
IN OUR A YES.
I THOUGHT I THOUGHT IT WAS CAL
GUNS FOR SOME REASON I'M SORRY --
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT -- I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT TO IS
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT FOURTH
AMENDMENT SEARCHES -- IF SOMEONE
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE ANY GUNS SUCH
AS WHAT HAPPENED A PARK WHEN
SHOOTING SURVIVOR DAVID HOG HE
WAS ONCE WANTED -- SOMEONE
CALLED THE COPS ON HIM AND HE
WASN'T HOME BUT IN OTHER
INCIDENCES PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SHOT.
BUT EVEN IF SOMEONE DOESN'T HAVE
ANY GUNS ANYTHING THAT -- IN
THEIR HOME WOULD BECOME
DISCOVERABLE AND SUBJECT -- TO
RESEARCH AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL SO WE STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT DISCUSSION
BY.
OF MY COLLEAGUES.
GO AHEAD SENATOR JEFF.
THANK YOU -- COULD YOU RESPOND
TO THE CONCERNS.
THAT WE COULD SEE -- POTENTIALLY --
POTENTIAL ABUSES BY PEOPLE WHO
MAY HAVE IT OUT FOR SOMEONE.
LEVELS OF DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON RACE ETHNICITY.
IMMIGRATION STATUS HOW HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS THAT IN THIS.
BILL BECAUSE IT SUPPORT WHAT YOU
TRYING TO GET AT JUST INTERESTED
IN HOW YOU GOING TO DEAL.
WITH THE POSSIBILITIES THAT THIS
COULD BE ABUSED BY PEOPLE OF ILL
INTENT.
BACK TO THE CORNERS -- QUESTION
SENATOR AS YOU RECALL SINCE --
YOURSELF AND CENTER SKINNER
CARRY THE ORIGINAL BILL THE
ORIGINAL BILL WAS ARE THE MAIN
ARGUMENT AGAINST THE BILL WAS
THAT WE WOULD SEE RAMPANT USE OF
THIS -- THESE TV ARE OWES THAT
WE WOULD HAVE.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF GUN
TAKE A GUNS TAKEN AWAY IN FACT
IN THREE YEARS THERE'S ONLY BEEN
UP APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN G. V. R. O. C. ISSUED
IN THE ENTIRE STATE.
MUCH OF THE MID THE MAJORITY BUT
A GREAT NUMBER HAVE BEEN ISSUED
BY THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY
MAR ELLIOTT -- IN FACT MANY OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE HAVEN'T EVEN
IMPLEMENTED POLICIES -- TO TO
USE GPRS IN FACT AND I'M ASHAMED
THAT MY OWN COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
AS WELL AS SAN MATTEO COUNTY I
DON'T BELIEVE A SINGLE DVR HAS
BEEN ISSUED OR IF THEY HAVE I
THINK IT'S UNDER I THINK IT'S
ONE RIGHT THANK YOU. ONE BETWEEN
THE TWO COUNTIES -- AND SO I
THINK THIS IS WHERE THIS WAS A
TOOL THAT -- I BELIEVE OUR BODY --
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT -- THEY
HAVE FOR WHATEVER REASON -- NOT
BEEN ABLE TO USE IT -- TO CHOSEN
NOT TO USE IT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SPECULATE.
BUT THIS ALLOWS -- THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE ACTUALLY UNDER THREAT
OF BEING BEING SHOT TO TAKE THE
POWER INTO THEIR OWN HANDS.
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR WORK PLACE
IS SAFE AND THAT THEIR SCHOOLS
ARE SAFE IN TERMS OF BIASES.
YOU HAVE A YOU HAVE TO GO GET
THE G. R. O. FROM A JUDGE I
WOULD HOPE THE JUDGE WOULD -- TO
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WAS ANY PARTICULAR BIAS AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME WITH THE USE
THAT JUDICIAL.
G. JUDICIAL RESTRAINT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ISN'T ANY BIAS.
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE NOT SEEN
LARGE NUMBERS OF DVR OWES ISSUED
IN THE STATE.
HEATHER -- JUSTIFY CAN RESPOND
PLEASE THE TO FACT TWO FACTORS
THAT WERE DESIGNED IN THE
ORIGINAL BILL WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
MODIFIED SERVICE IN STATUTE
RIGHT NOW. TO HELP MINIMIZE
ABUSES WAS AT THAT THEIR HOUSE
YOU HAVE TO IN.
PETITIONING FOR THE G. VERO SHOW
A DEMONSTRATED -- PROOF OF THE
PERSON BEING THREATENING
VIOLENCE TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
SECONDARILY IT IS A MISDEMEANOR.
IF YOU HAVE FILED A PETITION.
KNOWING THE INFORMATION IN THE
PETITION IS FALSE OR WITH THE
INTENT TO HARASS OR OTHER --
OTHER -- ITEMS WHICH THEN IS A
MISDEMEANOR WITH A FINE SO IT IS
BUILT INTO THE LAW TO IN EFFECT --
HAVE CONSEQUENCES TO ANYONE WHO
USES THIS FOR A REASON OTHER
THAN THE INTENT OF THE LAW.
SO THAT AND THAT WAS REALLY WHAT
I WAS GETTING I APPRECIATE THE
THE AUTHOR OF THE ORIGINAL BILL
CLARIFYING DISTANCE BILL ALSO
CONTAINED.
THOSE CAUTIONARY PRINCIPLES SO
THAT THE MODIFICATION TO THE
PENAL CODE WHERE THE G. P. R. O.
S. ESTABLISHED SO IT WOULD ALL
PLAY INCLUDING SUPPLY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
HER.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
GREAT AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS IS
PERFECT FOR ABOUT A NAY BE SIXTY
ONE THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WILL
DO ROLL CALL IN THIS BILL IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH
BRADFORD.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MITCHELL I'M AROUND WIENER.
BY BILL BE ON CALL UNTIL ARE
ABSENT MEMBERS RETURN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING.
AND WILL NOW GO -- TO ITEM I'M
NOT MR RUN CASES HERE.
APOLOGIES MS WEBER YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING BUT WOOD MISTER ROGERS
HERE WE DO FILE ORDER SO WE'LL
GO TO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
.
THREE OH THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I AM I HERE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH THREE TODAY SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF
COMMITTING A SEXUAL VIOLENT
OFFENSE.
AND WHO HAD BEEN AFTER BEING
EVALUATED BY MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL THE COURT FINDS
PROBABLE CAUSE A HERE SHE WOULD
ENGAGED IN SEXUALLY VIOLENT ACTS
UPON RELEASE.
I WENT TO COURT FINES ARE
PROBABLE CAUSE A FULL TRIAL MUST
BE HELD TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
S. V. P. SHOULD BE COMMITTED TO
STATE CUSTODY EVEN AFTER SERVING
HIS OR HER CRIMINAL SENTENCE.
HOWEVER THERE IS CURRENTLY
LITTLE STATUTORY GUIDANCE ABOUT
THE PROCEDURES FOR A COURT TO
ISSUE TROUT CONTINUANCE OR A
DELAY IN BEGINNING A TRIAL THIS
LACK OF GUIDANCE IS PROBLEMATIC
FOR TWO REASONS.
FIRST IT CAN LEAD TO OVERLY
LOGGING CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROBLEMATIC DELAYS IN BEGINNING
A TRIAL FOR INSTANCE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A LOS ANGELES
COURT RELEASED AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS AWAITING TRIAL FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS.
SECOND THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
FOR THE PARTY REQUESTING A
CONTINUANCE TO PROVIDE
JUSTIFICATION OR FOR THE COURT
TO JUSTIFY ITS DECISION TO ISSUE.
ONE THIS CAN LEAVE APPELLATE
COURTS WITH AN INCOMPLETE RECORD
TO LATER EXAMINE WHETHER
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATIONS
OCCURRED.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH THREE
WILL ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
FINALLY PROVIDING STATUTORY
GUIDANCE ON THE PROCEDURE FOR
ISSUING.
A CONTINUE ONCE IN A SB P. TRIAL.
THESE PROCEDURES INCLUDE A
REQUIREMENT THAT A MOTION FOR
CONTINUANCE BE MADE IN WRITING.
A REQUIREMENT THAT A CONTINUANCE
BE GRANTED ONLY UPON GOOD
BECAUSE AND IF THE CONTINUANCES
GRANTED A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
COURT PROVIDES A JUSTIFICATION
FOR ITS DECISION ON THE RECORD.
THIS BILL WILL KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SAFE BY HELPING TO PREVENT THE
RELEASE A SEXUALLY VIOLENT.
PREDATORS THAT WITHOUT A TRIAL.
IT WILL ALSO HELP ENSURE THAT
CONTINUANCES ARE GRANTED WITH
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION AND
THAT THERE IS A SUFFICIENT RIGHT --
FOR APPELLATE COURTS TO EXAMINE
DOWN THE LINE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A JUDICIAL CONCERN I
THAT THEY HAVE REYES ABOUT THE
PROCEDURES OUTLINED IN THIS BILL
FOR WORKING VERY CLOSE TO
FINALIZING AN AGREEMENT ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
HI THERE WE HOPE TO ADDRESS --
IN THE IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS SAID THAT SHOULD
THIS BILL CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD SENATORS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE TODAY ON AB
THREE OH THREE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL -- IN SUPPORT IS TOMAR
TOKAT NJ GROPES IN WITH THE LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO MARTEL CAUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE SPONSORING THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
A LENGTHY DELAYS AND SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR CASES IS A
STATE BY PROBLEM THAT WERE
HOPING IT.
WILL BE REMEDIED BY THIS BILL BY
ESTABLISHING CLEAR GUIDELINES
AND PROCEDURES FOR COURTS.
TO FOLLOW IN GRANTING
CONTINUANCES IN THESE CASES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND I HAVE WITH ME --
THE DEPUTY IN CHARGE OF OUR
OFFICES SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR UNIT JAKE ROBINSON
THANK YOU.
BOARDING THE HEAD OR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
AS OF AS OF MARCH OF THIS YEAR
THERE WERE FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT PEOPLE HELD A COLIN
THE STATE HOSPITAL PENDING TRIAL.
THAT'S REDUCTION FROM AUGUST OF
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY WERE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IS A LARGE
STAKEHOLDER WE HAVE THE MOST
INDIVIDUALS THERE OF THAT FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TEN FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I AM HAPPY TO SAY THAT TWO WEEKS
AGO WE WERE FINALLY ABLE TO
BRING TO TRIAL OUR LAST CASE
FROM THE NINETEEN NINETIES.
BUT THAT REMAINS OVER A HUNDRED
CASES FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE ARE OVER
TEN YEARS OLD.
THE GEORGE VASQUEZ CASE AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
REFERENCED SEVENTEEN YEARS.
THE PROBLEM HOWEVER IS NOT
UNIQUE TO LOS ANGELES I SPOKE
WITH COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
COUNTIES WHO HAVE SIMILAR
FRUSTRATIONS OVER THE INABILITY
TO BRING THESE CASES TO TRIAL.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO THE COURT OF
APPEAL UPHELD THE DISMISSAL OF
THE PETITION FOR MISTER CLAY
JONES.
MISTER JONES WAS FILED ON BY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DA'S OFFICE AS
SEXUAL VIOLENT PREDATOR IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN HE SOUGHT
A WRIT OF HABEAS CORPUS.
BECAUSE OF DELAYS IN BRINGING
HIS CASE TO TRIAL.
THE APPELLATE COURT UPHELD THE
DISMISSAL OF THE CASE NOTING
THERE WERE OVER TEN YEARS OF
DELAYS.
AND PERHAPS ITS MOST SIGNIFICANT
FOR OUR PURPOSES IS THAT THE
TRIAL COURT A CONDUCTING THE
HEARING SPECIFICALLY SAID.
THAT TWO OF HIS DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS THE PROSECUTION AND
THE COURT CONTRIBUTED TO THE
NUMEROUS DELAYS.
BY NOT DEMONSTRATING GOOD CAUSE
NOR INSISTING UPON OF SHOWING A
GOOD BECAUSE WHEN GRANTING
CONTINUANCES.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT AB THREE OH
THREE IS DESIGNED TO DO REQUIRED
THAT THERE BE SOME GOOD COST
FOUND TO CONTINUE TRIALS IN THIS
PETITIONS.
SO YOU DO NOT HAVE INDIVIDUALS
WHO SET THEIR LANGUISHING FOR
FIVE EIGHT TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
WITHOUT HAVING A TRIAL ON THE
MERITS OF THE PETITION.
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAINY PERIOD
WE HAVE FOR THIS HAMMER DINO
SHARE SOME PLEASE BENEVOLENT
ASSOCIATION AND POOR I CAN
SUPPORT.
BUT TERM MEMBER DAN FELIZ ON ON
BEHALF THE CRIME VICTIMS ACTUAL
LICENSE SUPPORT.
THE DOCTOR ARE REALLY -- ON
BEHALF OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
[inaudible]
I SUPPORT. TO SPEAK INLAND ON
THIS -- SUBJECT -- HOME
[inaudible]
SEXUAL PREDATORS.
IT'S A VERY OWN SINCE THE
SURGERY.
ALL.
THE SITUATION AROUND.
DEAL WITH PERSONALLY WITH THE
THE INDIVIDUAL -- AND YES OF TO
SHOULD BE DONE ABOUT IT.
AND USE IT IS HOME FROM SERVICE
WHAT CAN WE SPOKE ABOUT.
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS
AND EVERYTHING THAT THEY'RE
DOING.
ON YOUR BEHALF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING ON THIS BILL.
START FIRST TIME -- SO WE
KEEPING US THREE TIMES SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND ALSO A GANG RAPE
SURVIVOR -- I REPORTED.
A RAPIST TO THE SACK WHEN A
POLICE -- AS A BOMBING CAMPAIGN
STUFF FOR THE TIME AND I WAS
GANG RAPED KIDNAPPED RIGHT
BEFORE GET OUT THE VOTE.
SO -- STILL HAD TO GO BACK TO
WORK IN WHEN ELECTION BOTTOM THE
POLICE.
DIDN'T CONTACT ME FOR SEVEN
MONTHS.
AND AS I GOT SUPPORT SERVICES
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE -- I FOUND OUT
THT.
THE POLICE HAD SIMPLY SHELVES OF
MY REPORT.
AND SO.
IN MY OWN RESEARCH I FOUND OUT
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO RAPED ME
WE'RE BOTH ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FELL.
FELONY PROBATION AND WERE DUE IN
COURT THAT WEEK 420% DE WHY.
TRIAL AND SO WHEN WE HAVE
BACKLOGS.
LIKE THIS IT STARTS TO MAKE
SENSE WHY THESE CASES ARE NOT
GOING FORWARD WHY THEY'RE NOT
EVEN MAKING IT TO THE DA'S
OFFICE.
THERE ARE PROBLEMS IN THE SYSTEM
IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS BILL IS A
GREAT WAY TO RECTIFY THAT
BECAUSE WHY SHOULD ANYONE REPORT
A CRIME.
IF I WENT TO A SEVEN OUR BRAVE
CAT.
AND THEN NO NEVER FOLLOWED UP
WITH ME.
AND I HAD TO TALK TO THE CHIEF
OF POLICE THOSE WORKING WITH AS
A NEXT DOOR STAFFER
COLLABORATING THE SECOND POLICE.
WAS LIKE WHO DO YOU HAVE TO KNOW
TO FIND OUT.
WHY YOUR RATE WENT NOWHERE?
FRANK CELL -- THAT'LL BE A
LARGER DISCUSSION MAYBE I'LL
WORK WITH YOU ON SOMETHING LIKE
THAT BUT I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
STEP IN ME TOO HIGH SUPPORT.
FARM REPRIMAND SHORTY FROM
WHAT'S CALIFORNIA -- WANTS IS
TWO POINT ONE TWO MILES BE A
AROUND A BIOLOGY BUT I MAYOR
HOLLER MALLY WE HAVE THE PEOPLE
AT THE MY CAN JUST INDICATE
THEIR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
I DIDN'T WANT TO CUT OFF THE
LAST WITNESS BUT IF YOU COULD
JUST -- JERRY BRIEF -- WE'RE
WELL WE'RE SUPPORT OF A BECAUSE
WE'RE SURROUNDED BY FOUR MAJOR
HOUSING PROJECTS IN THESE PEOPLE
WERE RELEASED BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITY.
CONTINUING TO DO THE SAME THINGS
WITHOUT RECEIVER SOME TYPE OF
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SHARON RILEY ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE DO NOT HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE SPONSOR.
FOR WORKING WORKING WITH US WE
DO.
HAVE -- SOME PROCEDURAL CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY THE REQUIREMENT
THAT -- FINDINGS BE NOT ONLY
ENTERED INTO THE RECORD BUT ALSO
INTO THE MINUTES -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE ON A GOOD
PATH WITH AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT -- COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUES WERE MOTION THE BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
TODAY ON A. B. THREE OH THREE
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS -- WITH
THAT WE WILL TAKE RECALL.
INNER BY YOUR AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND WIENER.
I WILL HOLD THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL NOW GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
ITEM NINE AB.
THREE NINETY TWO GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I'M
HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB.
THREE NINE TWO THE CALIFORNIA
ACT TO SAVE LIVES.
I THINK IT'S CUSTOMARY HERE TO
SIMPLY DO THIS IF YOU'RE
PLOTTING.
OKAY THANK YOU YES THANK.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB THREE
NINE TWO THE CALIFORNIA ACT TO
SAVE LIVES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO RAISE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL STANDARD FOR
WHEN PLEASE CAN USE DEADLY FORCE
TO MATCH BEST PRACTICES ALREADY
IN PLACE THAT UP AT SOME
DEPARTMENTS.
AND THAT WE KNOW WORK TO KEEP
BOTH OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC
SAFE.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY WORK BECAUSE
OF THE BUY IN FROM THE COMMUNITY
AND FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
PLEASE OFFICE SHOULD NEVER TAKE
A HUMAN LIFE WHEN THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES.
SB THREE NINE TWO IS ABOUT
PREVENTING UNNECESSARY DEATHS BY
CLARIFYING LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
OBLIGATION WHEN MAKING THE
DECISION TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
AB THREE NINE TWO REPLACES THE
CURRENT VAGUE STANDARD THAT
OFFICES CAN USE DEADLY FORCE
WHENEVER REASONABLE STANDARD
WITH A HIGHER STANDARD.
THAT AUTHORIZES DEADLY FORCE
ONLY WHEN NECESSARY TO DEFEND
AGAINST AN IMMINENT DEATH THREAT
OF DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY
INJURY.
THE BILL IS SQUARELY IN LINE
WITH BEST PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS RECOGNIZED FOR
ACADEMICS AND EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND IS
MODELED AFTER POLICIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE AT SEVERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
PLEASE STAND ASIDE KNOWN TO
REDUCE SERIOUS USE OF FORCE
WITHOUT HAVING ANY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OFFICER SAFETY OR
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL ALL
AGENCIES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
UPDATE THE POLICIES TO INCLUDE
THESE BEST PRACTICES AND TO
ENSURE THAT OFFICERS ARE TRAINED
TO THE STANDARDS.
AB THREE NINE TWO IS SPONSORED
BY THE ACLU POLICY LINK A PICKLE
CALIFORNIA YOU'VE JUSTICE
COALITION ANTI POLICE TERROR
PROJECT COMMUNITIES NOT UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE USE JUSTICE.
FAMILIES UNITED FOR JUSTICE U.
D. W. AMERICA ASKED ME LOCAL
THREE NINE THIRTY THREE NINE
THIRTY STOP COALITION AND THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL HAS OVER
TWO HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT AND OVER A HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY IS A TEACHER BEER
AND THE MOTHER OF MARK MY RESEAL
BEER AND DION SOME IF THE MOTHER
OF JAMES RIVERA'S JUNIOR
ENGINEER WHO IS SISTER OF
CHARLIE SALINAS.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THE GREEN BUTTON [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HELLO MY NAME IS LUTETIA BEREN I
AM THE MOTHER OF MARIE CO PERRIN
JUNIOR.
I AM A MEMBER OF OUR REALITIES
IN YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION.
MY SON WAS KILLED OCTOBER TENTH.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BY
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICER DANIEL AG IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA.
A FEW DAYS EARLIER.
JUNIOR I CALL IT MY JUNIOR.
US LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR HELP
REGARDING A SAFETY CONCERN.
HE WAS FEARFUL THAT SOMEONE WAS
THREATENING HIM HE HAD NO
HISTORY OF MENTAL ILLNESS YET
LAW ENFORCEMENT DIDN'T TAKE.
HIS CONCERNS SERIOUSLY.
HE BECAME MORE AND MORE
DISTRESSED THERE IS MORE TO HIS
STORY YOU'LL BE HEARING.
ON THE DAY HE WAS SHOT JUNIOR
WAS PANICKING OVER HIS SAFETY.
UNFORTUNATELY HE ENDED UP
WALKING ON THE INTERSTATE FIVE
FREEWAY.
IN IRVINE.
CALIFORNIA HE WAS HIT BY A CAR
IT'S SIXTY FIVE MILES AN HOUR.
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED CALLS CAME IN
TO NINE ONE ONE REPORTING THAT A
PEDESTRIAN WAS HIT BY A CAR.
OFFICER AG CAME TO THE SCENE
ANSWERING A CALL.
ONLY THAT A PEDESTRIAN WAS HIT
ON THE FREEWAY.
AND HIT BY THE CAR IN CIVIL
COURT IT WAS REVEALED THAT
WITHIN SECONDS OF ARRIVING AT
THE SCENE.
OFFICER AG SHOT AND KILLED MY
SON.
HE CLAIMED THAT JUNIOR WAS
MOVING TOWARD HIM FAST.
YELLING AT THE OFFICER BUT THE
AUTOPSY SHOWED THAT JETER HAD
SUFFERED A BROKEN FOOT A BROKEN
HAIR ON FRACTURED NECK.
OF FRACTURED LARYNX WITH HIS
INJURIES JUNIOR COULD NOT MOVE
FAST.
AND HE COULD NOT SPEAK LET ALONE
YELL AT THE OFFICER.
OFFICER AG MADE NO EFFORT TO DE
ESCALATE THE SITUATION.
HE FIRED THREE SHOTS TO HIT
JUNIOR ONE TO THE HEAD SEVEN
FEET AWAY FROM HIM AND WENT TO
THE REST.
THE BELL ON THE CHEER HAD HIS
HANDS UP BECAUSE OF ONE OF THE
BULLETS HIT IS INSIDE FOR OUR ON
THE DAY HE WAS KILLED HE HAD
CALLED BOND FOR SPENT REPEATEDLY.
TO REPORT WE HAD CALLED LAW
ENFORCEMENT I'M SORRY TO REPORT
JUNIOR WAS MISSING.
NO ONE TOLD US THAT HE HAD BEEN
KILLED IN AN OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING.
AFTER THREE HOURS OF SEARCHING
WE STARTED CALLING HOSPITALS.
WE HEARD NOTHING UNTIL MY
DAUGHTER CARLA WHO'S PRESENT
HERE TODAY.
MADE A PUBLIC PLEA ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
LOOKING FOR HER BROTHER SOMEONE
RESPONDED SAID THERE WAS A
GENTLEMAN THAT LOOK LIKE HER
BROTHER ON THE FREEWAY.
COMMENTING ABOUT IT MA'AM ON THE
FREEWAY IN IRVINE SHOT BY
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
DEAR ONE SHOT AT SEVEN TEN PM.
HE WAS PRONOUNCED DEAD AT EIGHT
FOURTEEN AT THE HOSPITAL WE DID
NOT ARRIVE TO THE HOSPITAL UNTIL
NINE THIRTY FROM RIVERSIDE.
BUT NO ONE GAVE US ANY
INDICATION.
THAT HE WAS DEAD.
THE IS STUCK US IN A ROOM
MERGING SEE ROOM -- NOBODY TOLD
US THE HOSPITAL STAFF WE DIDN'T
HEAR FROM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
UNTIL SIX HOURS LATER.
THAT YEAR HAD BEEN KILLED.
WE WERE STUCK IN THEIR ROOM AND
AT TEN O'CLOCK NEWS.
EVEN THOUGH HE CAME IN WE SAW I
THAT'S HOW I SAW MY SON ON TV.
KNOWING THAT HE HAD SUCCUMBED TO
HIS INJURIES WALL.
OFFICER PAUL PARKS WAS DOING A
LIVE FEED OUTSIDE OUT FRONT OF
THE HOSPITAL WELL I WAS IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM I WASN'T EVEN
ABLE TO GET A PRIEST.
TO GET MY SON'S LAST RITES.
MY SON WAS KILLED TWO WEEKS
BEFORE HIS TWENTY EIGHTH
BIRTHDAY HE WAS MY FIRST PORTS
THAT.
THE WAS LEVY KERRY ALWAYS GIVING.
SORRY HE WOULD GO OUT OF HIS WAY
TO HELP OTHERS.
HE WAS CREATIVE HE MADE MUSIC HE
WAS TAKING THE ACTOR HE WAS A
TAP DANCER.
HE WAS ALSO A BLACK BELT IN THE
ART OF JUDGES -- TO HE TAUGHT
SELF DEFENSE TO UNIVERSITIES AB
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. FOR
SELF DEFENSE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PETER.
DEBBIE CLUB THE RAKES THROUGH
HIS EDUCATION APPRENTICESHIPS.
HE WAS TO BE CABIN INSPECTOR FOR
OSHA IT ABOUT -- OF THREE WEEKS
BEFORE YOU GOT KILLED.
LIVE HIS LIFE WITH INTEGRITY
RESPECT HE RESPECTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HE WAS NEVER EVER IN TROUBLE
WITH THE LAW.
EVERY WHAT IT BY FAMILY HAS BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY JETER'S
KILLY.
AS IT HAS AFFECTED BY REMAINING
CHILDREN MY GRANDCHILDREN THEY
CAL IS FAB LEAVE FRANCE.
OLDEST DAUGHTER CARLA IS HERE
TODAY RIGHT BECAUSE OF VALERIE.
MY GRANDDAUGHTER NATALIE.
IT ALL BUT FRIENDS. TWO YEARS
WERE MORRELL SERVICE WAS ON HIS
BIRTHDAY [inaudible]
HIS BIRTHDAY.
HIS FUNERAL WAS AWED BY DAUGHTER
CARLA'S BIRTHDAY.
THE NEXT DAY WE HAVE TO LIVE
WITHOUT THE REST OF OUR LIVES.
AB THREE DAY TWO IS A BOARD TO
BE BECAUSE MAYES SAID SITUATION
COULD HAVE ENDED DIFFERENTLY.
WE'VE HE WOULD STILL BE ALIVE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT USE OF FORCE
REQUIRED THAT IT WAS NECESSARY
TO PREVENT AN IMMINENT THREAT OF
DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
JETER WAS UNARMED SEVERELY
INJURED AND HAVING HAD NO PRIOR
CONTACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
NOT A THREAT.
HE WAS NOT SUICIDE BY COP.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IT
PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB THREE DIED
[inaudible]
TOO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS.
TO TALK ABOUT SOMEONE IMPORTANT
TO US WHO'VE LOST.
CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JANUARY'S.
ANDA I AM HERE -- WITH THE STOP
COALITION.
THIS PAST WEEK MARK SEVEN YEARS
SINCE MY BROTHER CHARLIE SALINAS
WAS KILLED BY SINGLE POLICE.
A BLOCK AWAY FROM MY CHILDHOOD
HOME.
THE SEVEN YEARS HAVE BEEN FILLED
WITH TRAUMA CONFUSION IN JUSTICE
BUT NOW FINALLY HOPE FOR CHANGE.
MY LITTLE BROTHER WAS A GOOD AND
GENTLE MAN.
HE LOVES SPORTS MARINE TENNIS
FAMILY WOULD ALSO A VETERAN WHO
STRUGGLED WITH DEPRESSION.
POST TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
ON THE DAY HE WAS KILLED CHARLIE
AND CALL 911- ON HIMSELF AND
TOLD A DISPATCHER THAT HE WANTED
TO DIE.
HE WAS EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS HE NEEDED HELP.
INSTEAD OF POLICE WHO ARRIVED
FIRED TWENTY TWO BULLETS AT HIM.
ONE CHARLIE WAS SHOT HIS HANDS
WERE IN THE AIR HE WAS FOLLOWING
INSTRUCTIONS BUT NON DEADLY
OPTIONS WERE NOT PURSUED.
WHAT IS CALIFORNIA ALLOW PEOPLE
TO KILL PEOPLE?
WHEN IT'S NOT NECESSARY TO
PROTECT FROM AN IMMINENT THREAT?
CHARLIE WAS NO THREAT THAT DAY.
FOR FARTOO LONG CALIFORNIA HAS
IGNORE THE PROBLEM OF POLICE
SHOOTINGS AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATE KILLING THE
BLACK AND LATINO CALIFORNIANS
AND THOSE WITH DISABILITIES.
AB THREE NINETY TWO FINALLY
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM HEAD ON
WITH SOLUTIONS THAT WE KNOW WORK.
REFORMING OUR ARE OUTDATED
STANDARD IS COMMON.
SEATTLE FOR AN EXAMPLE HAS SEEN
A REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF USE
OF FORCE INCIDENCES.
AFTER ADOPTING A STANDARD
SIMILAR TO THE ONE IN CALIFORNIA
AT TO SAVE LIVES.
OFFICERS HAVE REMAINED JUST TO
SAVE.
WE GIVE OFFICERS.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT POWER WE
GIVE TO ANY PUBLIC EMPLOYEE THE
POWER OF LIFE AND DEATH OVER US
WE MUST MAKE SURE THE POLICE USE
THAT POWER JUDICIOUSLY.
WITH RESPECT TO HUMAN RIGHTS AND
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN THE
SANCTITY OF ALL HUMAN LIFE AND
ONLY WHEN ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
WE MUST ALSO HOLD POLICE
ACCOUNTABLE WHENEVER THEY MISS
USE THAT POWER.
UNDER AB THREE NINETY TWO COURTS
WILL GROUP ACQUIRED TO CONSIDER
THE OFFICER'S ACTIONS LEADING UP
TO THE USE OF DEADLY FORCE AS
PART OF THE STOP COALITION I
SUPPORT AN ADVOCATE WITH DOZENS
OF OTHER FAMILIES.
LEVEL AND WERE KILLED BY THE
POLICE IN NEARLY EVERY CASE NO
ONE WAS HELD ACCOUNTABLE NO
POLICIES WOULD CHANGE PREVENT
FUTURE TRAGEDIES.
MY BROTHER SUFFERED A LOT IN
THIS LIFE THAT DAY HE JUST
NEEDED HELP.
HE DIDN'T DESERVE TO BE KILLED.
HE DESERVED COMPASSION.
AND HE DESERVED RESPECT FOR THE
SANCTITY OF HIS LIFE.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY WANTS TO
DIE DOESN'T MEAN POLLUTION
SHOULD THEM.
IF AB THREE NINETY TWO PASSES
CALIFORNIA WILL GO FROM HAVING
ONE OF THE DEADLIEST USE OF
FORCE.
LAWS IN THE COUNTRY TO HAVING
ONE OF THE MOST PROTECTIVE LAWS
IN THE COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE THE ONLY STATE TO
COMBINE THE NECESSARY STANDARD.
WITH THE REQUIREMENT THAT COURTS
CONSIDER OFFICERS CONDUCT
LEADING UP TO THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE.
IN DETERMINING ITS ILLEGALITY.
NONE OF THIS COULD MAKE.
A POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
LEADERSHIP AND COURAGE OF THE
COUNTLESS FAMILIES WHO LOST
LOVED ONES TO POLICE VIOLENCE
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN LIVE WITH
DIGNITY.
AND FREE FROM THE FEAR OF POLICE
VIOLENCE AB THREE NINETY TWO IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
TOWARD GREATER APPRECIATION OF
LIFE INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
SUICIDAL AND STUFF BRING.
AND TOWARD JUSTICE FOR OUR LOST
LOVED ONES.
THIS IS HOW I WILL HONOR MY
BROTHER'S LIFE.
MY FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
OTHER FAMILIES DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH WHAT WE'VE GONE.
PASS A BE THREE NINETY TWO TODAY
LET US LIVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT -- WITNESS.
YES MY NAME IS DIONNE SMITH
DOWNS.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MY SON
CHANGE FOR THEIR OWN JUNIOR WHO
WAS EXECUTED IN SORT OF A GARAGE --
THE COMMITTEE. TO PASS AB THREE
NINE TWO CALIFORNIA TO STABILIZE.
I AM ALSO HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
NEED TO TELL MY SON STORY.
EVERY TIME I THINK ABOUT IT ON
ARGUED [inaudible]
TODAY AND TODAY'S OPPORTUNE TO
LET YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT MY
SON AND HOW.
A BILL ABOUT SB THREE NINE SOON.
MY SON JAMES RIVER.
NUMBER SEVEN OUT OF FOURTEEN
JANE LOCUSTS FAMILY.
HIS COMMUNITY IN IS FRANCE.
JAMES WAS LORD.
LOW'S FIXING THINGS.
HE LOW MOTOR SCOOTERS BY BECAUSE
HE WAS ALSO GOOD WITH HIS HANDS.
WE HAD A FUN FAMILY FURNITURE
STORE.
IN STOCKTON.
AND HE WAS ALWAYS HAVE BEEN --
SOMEONE FURNITURE HE WAS A KID.
I HAVE BEEN HERE.
HE LOVE HOLIDAYS [inaudible]
HE LOVE.
WHEN WE ALL COME TOGETHER HIS
COUSINS NIECES NEPHEWS TO
CELEBRATE?
HE WAS JUST A REGULAR SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD KID.
HE HAD A DURING.
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR TO HIS
BIRTHDAY.
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
WE ARE ALL SO EXCITED TO PLAN
HIS [inaudible]
BIRTHDAY.
WITH MY MOM MY SISTERS AND
EVERYONE.
WE WENT OUT AND BOUGHT HIM A
CAKE.
WE WILL BE READY FOR TO HAVE A
BIG BLOW OUT BECAUSE THE WARNING
A BIG.
OLD.
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
HE WAS TURNING.
BECAUSE HE WAS A BIG KID AT
HEART.
BUT HE NEVER.
MADE IT TO SEE HIS SEVENTEENTH
BIRTHDAY.
ON JULY TWENTY SECOND TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN CHEN WAS.
KILLED BY STOCKTON PONIES AND
ONE SURE.
THE DUTY OF STOCKTON.
A DAY BEFORE HIS BIRTHDAY.
JAMES LOVE HIS LIFE.
JAMES LOVES HIS FAMILY.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DIE.
THE COMMUNITY LOVE HIM HE HAD
TOUCHED SO MANY PEOPLE IN HEART
[inaudible]
HE HELPED.
PEOPLE FIX THEIR WASHING
MACHINES THEIR BIKES ANYTHING.
THE US WHY THE COMMUNITY WANTS
OUT.
AND CELEBRATED HIS BIRTHDAY.
WITH US THE COMMUNITY BUT DID A
BARBECUE OWNER OF MY SON.
THEY PAY FOR EVERYTHING.
IN THROUGH.
THE BIG BIRTHDAY PARTY.
WARNING BECAUSE HE WAS FIELD OF
LIFE AND THEY WANTED TO
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
IT WILL SEARCH
.
HOW MANY BARS HERE?
HOW MANY SIGN WAS GONE?
HE WOULDN'T LET ME SEE THEY WILL
LET ME SEE HIM [inaudible]
WHEN?
I WOULD TO THE HOT -- WENT.
TO SEARS MIA -- SO.
JUST LIKE BRING IT MEMORIES LIKE
IT JUST HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
I WENT TO THE HOSPITAL AND ONCE
I WALKED INTO SOME WALKING YOUR
HOUSE WERE DOORS TO EXPLAIN IT.
I WANTED TO HOLD MY SON FOR THE
LAST TIME I WAS ONLY ABLE TO SEE
HIM THROUGH A TINY WINDOW.
WHEN I SAW HIM HE LOOKED LIKE A
MUMMY?
IT WAS TOO MUCH TO BEAR.
WHEN HE WAS AT THE HOSPITAL HE
WAS CHECKED IN UNDER A DIFFERENT
NAME JONDO?
THEY HAD HIS AGE OF A HUNDRED
AND NINE YEARS OLD.
THIS IS WHAT FAMILY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH NOT ONLY THE IS OUR LOVE
ONE LONG.
WHAT DISRESPECTED?
LIKE.
LIKE THIS AND WE HAD TO JUMP.
THROUGH LOOPS IN HOPES TO GET
ANSWERS.
WHERE THE FEDERAL?
VALLEY GAP OF HIS BODY I TRIED
TO SEE HIM.
BUT THEY SAID NO.
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE YOUR
SON.
LIKE THIS.
GIVE US TIME TO GET HIM READY
FOR THE V. ON OUR SAID NO.
I SAID A BAD WORD.
TO WHERE ARE.
VALLEY GOT TO SEE HIM.
ARE THE SONGS.
THAT.
THERE WAS A HOLE IN HIS HEAD
SIDE OF A GOLF BALL.
IN HIS ARM WAS BROKEN.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED TO MY SON.
START LOOKING FOR ANSWERS
[inaudible]
KILL THIS
.
WHAT HAPPENED TO JAMES NINE
YEARS LATER AB VALLEY?
GET ANSWERS.
WE START TRIAL SEPTEMBER OF THIS
YEAR.
THERE ARE AUTOPSY PHOTOS OF MY
SON.
NO MOTHER SHOULD EVER HAVE TO
SEE THIS.
IF ANY OF YOU HAVE CHILDREN I
HOPE YOU NEVER HAVE TO SEE YOUR
CHILD OR LOW ONE LIKE THIS.
THIS IS WHY I THINK A. B. SHOULD
BE PASSED.
POLICE OFFICER MURDER I LOVE
ONES AND TAKE EVERYTHING FROM US.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM.
WE ARE THE OUR WHICH THE BILL
WAS IN PLACE.
BECAUSE MASA WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
EXECUTED.
THEY WOULDN'T LOOK AT HIM
[inaudible]
AT THAT [inaudible]
LARGEST BILLS.
THE END OF THIS BILL WHO WAS IN
PLACE [inaudible]
MY SON.
WOULDN'T HAVE NOT BEEN EXECUTED
INSIDE OF A GARAGE ONCE THEY GET
A PAPERNO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MENTAL CAR INTO TO MAIL BOX INTO
THE GARAGE.
SHOULD BE FORTY EIGHT ROUNDS IN
EIGHTEEN HINTED HIM.
THAT WAS OVER KILL.
EACH BULLET SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS HAVE TO STOP.
OUR FAMILY HAVE TO SEE.
THIS ARE THESE BODIES LIKE THIS.
WE THINK IT WILL.
WILL.
HAPPEN TO YOU WOMEN A SCHISM I
WISH THIS BILL WAS IN PLACE
BECAUSE MY SON WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN EXECUTED.
THEY WOULD HAVE LOOKED AT HIM
OKAY.
WE NEVER THANK YOU WILL HAPPEN
TO US UNTIL THEY DID.
WE NEED TO STOP -- SHOOTING
BEFORE THEY HAPPEN.
IT SHOULDN'T HAVE TO TAKE A
NUMBER DOWN FOR THE LAW TO FOUND
CHANGE TODAY IS MY FAMILY.
TOMORROW IT COULD BE YOUR FAMILY.
LET IN TODAY FOR THOSE REASONS.
ARE YOU ARE ACTION TO VOTE YES
ON A. B..
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU NO
JUSTICE NO PEACE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
NOW THE FOLKS THAT ARE LINED UP.
PLEASE YOUR NAME AND YOUR ON I'M
ASSUMING WE'RE ALL EVERYONE
LINED UP RIGHT NOW IS THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PROCEED ANGELA WILLIAMS
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
IN FULL SUPPORT.
MAKE SURE THE REGIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT LOS ANGELES BAY PACKED
IN SUPPORT.
I'M DAVID PHILLIPS OF FATHER
DEAD MEN FILL OF MURDERED THREE
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN FIVE
OFFICERS THREE OF THE FIVE
OFFICERS.
THAT MURDERED MY SON HAD BEEN TO
MY HOUSE BEFORE THEY NEW DEAD
MINT HAVE PTSD.
THIS TIME NO WARNING NO NOTHING
NO KNOCK ON THE DOOR TO CALLPOLICE ON THE DOOR WHEN THEY
KICKED THE DOOR IN.
AGAIN NOTHING THIS IS WHAT IT IS
THIS IS REALITY BUT AGAIN NO NO
COMMANDS NO NOTHING RAISE YOUR
HAND OR YOU'LL BE TAY'S GET ON
THE GROUND YOU'LL BE TASTE NONE
OF THAT.
KICKED THE DOOR IN TATE'S IN TWO
SECONDS LATER OVER SIXTEEN SHOT
I CALLED AT EIGHT O'CLOCK. EIGHT
THIRTEEN MY SON [inaudible]
IS DEAD.
NINETY TWO BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY I'M LEAVING HERE AND I'M
GOING TO THE CEMETERY THAT'S
WHERE I'M GOING.
THIS MY BABY.
AB.
THREE NINETY THANK YOU -- I'M
SORRY IT'S HOMES WITH THE USE US
COALITION ON HERE ON THE BEHALF
OF RAIN JOSEPH WHO WAS KILLED BY
LAPD IN.
OUR STRONG LOOP I STRONGLY
OPPOSE USE.
PASSES WILL.
I'M JOHN I'M JOHN SAM USES I'M
HERE ON BEHALF HIZO FORWARD.
BIG ARCTIC CAT THEY GOT SHOT IN
THE BACK WHILE ON HIS KNEES BY.
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT LOS ANGELES
PLEASE PAST.
THREE NINETY TWO CARLA BARREN OF
RIVERSIDE STILL THE SISTER OF OF
THE SHOW VERY.
FROM A STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WICHITA AS WITH CHIRLA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS BILL.
PLEASE MAILER AMNESTY
INTERNATIONAL WHICH OFFICIALLY
THINKS THE BILL SHOULD BE MUCH
STRONGER BUT I'M HERE TO THANK
THE AUTHORS IN THE LEADERSHIP.
FOR GETTING US THIS FAR THE
SUPPORT.
JEEZY DEAN THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LAURIE PASSANTE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOTUS WORK THE FOUNDATION AND
PERSONALLY AS THE DAUGHTER OF
TWO LOS ANGELES SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THREE NINETY TWO ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE OF US IN BAKERSFIELD WHERE
SIX TIMES MORE LIKELY AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO BE SHOT BY
BAKERSFIELD POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND LATINOS FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE SHOT BY BAKERSFIELD
POLICE DEPARTMENT STRONG SUPPORT
PLEASE YES ON THREE NINETY TWO
GOOD MORNING KAELIN DEAN WITH
BOTH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY LINK.
PROUD CO SPONSORS IN SUPPORT OF
THREE NINETY TWO AB CARMEN ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINE TWO ELLEN CHAPMAN
WITH INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO STATE
STRONG IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY OFFICE
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT.
DARCY VINYL WITH THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO -- MAINLY RESTAURANTS
SUPPORT OF AB -- THREE NINETY
TWO THE DENISE FRIDAY
[inaudible]
MY SON.
CALL THE FRIDAY.
WAS ASSASSINATED BY DAVID WELLS.
TWENTY SIXTEEN FOR MISTAKEN
IDENTITY.
HE WAS THE WRONG PERSON.
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
AB.
NINETY TWO BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
IF THIS WAS ALREADY IN ORDER TO
WIN AND NEVER HAPPENED TO MY SON
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FAMILIES UNITED FOR JUSTICE AND
LOYALTY AND FAMILY AND A
MOTHER'S VOICE FOR CHANGE.
JIM WENT LIMBURGER ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
NATASHA MINSKER ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARGOT INDO WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CECILE NUNLEY ON
BEHALF OF BLACK WOMEN UNITED WE
WILL BE HAVING OUR MARCH AND WE
WILL BE LOOKING AND WATCHING
OVER TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS WHAT
WE WATCHING ALL OF FEEL.
THANK YOU IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HE WON KIPLING MAJORITY WITH THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
WERE WE VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL [inaudible]
UNCLE BOBBY.
CALIFORNIA FOUNDED UNITED FOR
JUSTICE -- STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THERE'SNO HIGHER
COMPATIBLE.
TO THE DAILY USE OF FORCE THAT
TAKES A LOT OF ONE'S LIFE.
AND IS FORCING YOUR MEMORY
FOREVER AS YOU HEARD BEYOND
SPEAKING OF THE MOTHERS.
BUT IT COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
SB THREE NINETY TO GIVES US THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO STOP THIS TYPE OF
PAIN HAPPEN TO FAMILIES.
MY NAME IS A QUITTER THOMPSON ON
THE GRANDMOTHER OF STEFAN CLARK
AND I WANT EVERYONE TO VOTE YES
ON ABC.
ABC.
THREE NINETY TO PROTEST IS THAT
OF ALL THE CALIFORNIA YOUNG MEN.
AND WOMEN.
MY NAME IS JIM MILLION LAND.
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED FOR
JUSTICE.
BAY PACKED MARGARINE IN EVERY
CALIFORNIA FAMILY MEMBER.
WHO HAS LOST A LOVED?
ONE WE STAND HERE TODAY IN
SOLIDARITY FOR THIS PASSAGE OF
AB.
THREE NINETY TWO SO THAT WE CAN
IN THE DEADLY USE OF FORCE.
THAT HAS BEEN TAKING --
COUNTLESS LIVES OF ALARM
CITIZENS.
IN THE WORDS OF DOMINIC
ARCHIBALD MOTHER OF NAY TH
ANNUAL PICKET. TWO TIME ARMY
COMBAT VETERAN.
SHE HAS STATED THAT THERE ARE
MORE NO RULES OF ENGAGEMENT. FOR
NO ENEMY COMBATANTS IN THE
MILITARY.
THE WHAT WE SEE ON THE STREETS
OF CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY EVERY DAY.
AT THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH AN ARM CITIZENS WE SUPPORT
THE PASSAGE OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO MY A SHANK HERE
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH ALL
THE MANY FAMILIES HERE THAT HAVE
BEEN INFECTED.
SELECT ITS USE ME AND INFLICTED
BY GUN VIOLENCE IN THE HANDS OF
POLICE OFFICERS I STRONGLY
APPROVE AB THREE NINETY TWO
THANK YOU.
WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT?
TIFFANY ONE WITH A CA CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF OUR SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND PROUD
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAKER UC BERKELEY
SOCIAL WELFARE DEPARTMENTS FROM
SUPPORT.
COLIN QUICK BAY AREA STERN
ACTIVISTS STRONG SUPPORT.
COLOR MONITOR ON BEHALF OF THE
SACK COUNTY YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DONNA WOULD SEKHEMRE VALLEY
SECTION OF THE NATIONAL
COALITION OF BLACK WOMEN.
WE SUPPORT PROUDLY.
THREE NINETY TWO MY NAME IS THAT
MISSION LEARNING WILL Y. J. C.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
PROBLEMS WHO WAS KILLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT STRONG SUPPORT OF A.
B..
MY NAME IS LEAH.
MY NAME IS LEAH IN OUR LUNCH IS
A FOR IT A. B..
THREE NINETY TWO AS MY DAUGHTER
I AM TO LAST MINUTE -- FROM GIVE
JUSTICE COALITION I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY --
TOLLYWOOD SUICIDA BACK BY LIMITS
PLEASE DEPARTMENT ALSO HECTOR MY
OWN WHO SHOT.
THAT AND NOW -- ABANDONED
BUILDING TAG AND ALSO -- HAVE
SUPPORT.
TO NINETY TWO THE LIST GOES ON
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS ADAMS AND
I'M WITH THE PEOPLE'S ALLIANCE
FOR JUSTICE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE WOULD
ACTUALLY GUYS TO GET THIS BILL
PASSED AND GET IT MOVED -- FOR
OUR NATIONAL PRESIDENT RIVER
SHANE HARRIS HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME ADVOCATE -- FOR POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICE MISCONDUCT -- WE'VE DEALT
WITH MANY FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN
KILLED ARE NEARLY KILLED -- BY
POLICE INJUSTICES AND WE'RE ALSO
TAKEN ON A CASE RIGHT NOW AREN'T
SUPPORTED JAMES WEAVER --
STOCKED A MAN WHO HAS BEEN --
THEY PULLED OUT A GUN UP ON HIM
AND MISTREATED HIM AND USING
EXCESSIVE FORCE AND WERE IN
SUPPORT OF HELPING OUT ANY
FAMILY HOUSE DEAL WITH ANY TYPE
AND JUSTICEFOR THE PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE SERVICE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GINA MARTINEZ WITH
THE FRESNO ACL UNIT -- ALSO A
FAMILY MEMBER OF THE STEVEN
TWELVE PACK VARGAS OF FRESNO
SHOT AND KILLED NINE TIMES BY
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT HE WAS
UNCONSCIOUS AND ON DRUGS HIT A
PARKED CAR.
POLICE WERE FOUND THE THE POLICE
OFFICER WAS FOUND LIABLE IN
FEDERAL COURT THE CITY WAS FOUND
LIABLE IN SAID IN THE FEDERAL
COURT AS WELL SETTLEMENT WAS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE CHANGED.
FRESNO PD THEY'RE MORE TRIGGER
HAPPY TODAY AND AB THREE NIGHTS
TO WILL MAKE THAT CHANGE SO THAT
IT PLAYS THE STANDARDS TO
NECESSARY INSTEAD OF REASONABLE
THIS AMBIGUOUS PLEASE SUPPORT A.
B..
THREE NINETY TWO I LIKE I'LL
ORTEGA I'M WITH THE ACLU OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ALSO AS
AN OAKLAND RESIDENT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE NINETY TILL.
HELLO AGAIN ONE IS NOT THEY ARE
RUDE.
AND ON BEHALF OF BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND THEN.
YOU JUSTICE COALITION MUSSET
HANDS UP.
DON'T SHOOT WE'RE REALLY SAYING
IS.
BE QUICK TO UNDERSTAND IS SLOW
TO GRAB YOU KERN.
NEED TO BE BETTER POLICIES.
AND PROCEDURES. TO THE POLICE
ABOUT THESE.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE ABOUT
IT BECAUSE LAWS OUR STATE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
AND THE CHARMANDER GROUP THE
FAMILY SUFFER.
AS THEY CRIED UP THERE.
THEY DON'T DESERVE THAT THE
DESERVE BETTER.
AND THANKS FOR LET ME SPEAK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOLPHIN BRODY WITH MY LOVE
UNDERGROUND AND THE TRANSCEND ON
BINARY HOUSING COLLECTIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO UNDER THE HEAD
OF THE LAST GOAL REPRESENTING.
BATTLE OF UNDERGROUND AND HAS
NON BINDING HOUSING COLLECTIVE
THE STRONG SUPPORT.
I CAME FROM A AND ALMA MATER OF
NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
AND THERE WAS A MENTOR.
OF A RAPPER AND A FORMER.
A FORMER -- HE WAS A MENTOR FOR
MISTER OF THE SAME NAPA COLLEGE
I WENT.
TO HE GOT MURDER FOR A SHOOTING
OF THE DEAL.
AND IRONICALLY IT WAS FROM.
THE OFFICER WAS FROM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE OF NAPA VALLEY
COLLEGE.
GUNS ARE KILLING THEIR OWN.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I AM ELIZABETH ADAM ON THE
MOTHER OF A ROBERT AT ROBERT
CANNING.
JUSTICE FOR BOBBI HENNING.
AM.
IF THIS BILL HAD BEEN IN PLACE
BOBBY'S LIFE WOULD SURELY.
BEGIN SAVED -- HE WAS SURROUNDED
BY FIVE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S THEY HAD BEEN BAGS
THEY HAD A A PEPPER SPRAY.
AND WE HAD AN EYEWITNESS SAID
SAID BOBBY WAS COMPLETELY NON
VIOLENT AND YET HE ENDED UP DEAD
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE STREET BUT
TO SHOCK AND BLAST.
TO HIS INTERNAL ORGANS SO I BEG
YOU PLEASE THIS IS A GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BOBBY LEFT THE
STADIUM WITH COMPETITIVE
SNOWBOARDER AND SKATEBOARDER.
AND IASK YOU PLEASE TO PASS
THIS BILL SO WE COULD BE EXAMPLE
TO THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SEVERAL ADAM.
THE BOBBI HENNING WAS MY STEP
SON.
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO HAD CARRILLO
POOR ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
ACLU.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
AND SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
INDIVISIBLE.
WE ALL CONSIDER THIS BILL TO BE
VITAL FOR THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND GOOD OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
PLEASE PASSAGE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DAVID GAINES I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER
LOCATED IN OAKLAND.
I WILL SAY THAT -- THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM THAT IS THISIS A
PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN HERE FOR A
LONG TIME -- PEOPLE.
EVERYWHERE ARE JUST LOOKING FOR
HOPE.
HOPE FOR CHANGE HOPE TO LIVE --
NOBODY ELSE WOULD HAVE TO DIE.
DR KING TEACHES US THAT
NONVIOLENCE IS NOT JUST THE
ABSENCE OF VIOLENCE BUT THE
PRESENCE OF JUSTICEAB THREE
NINE TWO WILL GIVE US THAT
PRESENCE OF JUSTICE.
THE FREEDOM CENTER STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB.
THREE NINE TWO SO I SEE HIM HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
KAREN BOCHY ALSO WITH THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR FREEDOM
CENTER AND JUST A QUICK WORD OF
THANKS TO A DOCTOR WEBER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
INITIATIVE AND TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S NOT JUST THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
BENEFIT FROM AB.
THREE NINETY TWO IT'S THE PEOPLE
OF OUR NATION WHO WERE LOOKING
FOR HOPE AND AN ALTERNATIVE
NARRATIVE TO THE VIOLENCE AND
THE RHETORIC RHETORIC AND THE
MEANNESS THAT'S BEING
PERPETRATED AND CARRIED OUT.
UNDER SOME AWFULLY DIVISIVE
BOUNCE UP BANNERS IN OUR NATION
TODAY THANK YOU ALL.
CAROL YORK I'M HERE WITH A GROUP
THAT I'M SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I
AM A CHILD DEVELOPMENT ASSISTANT
FOR HEAD START.
AND WE HOLD OUR CHILDREN
ACCOUNTABLE I WOULD PASS PLEASE
PASS THREE NINETY TWO SO THAT WE
CAN HOLD OUR POLICE OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE THANK YOU.
EILEEN SCHNITGER OMIT CITIZEN OF
SACRAMENTO STOP COPS FROM
KILLING BLACK CALIFORNIANS
PASSED THREE NINETY TWO THANK
YOU DOCTOR [inaudible]
SIR -- CARES WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY RABBITS J. ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF SAN FRANCISCO.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
COMPROMISE AND I'M URGING THIS
COMMITTEE TO DO THE SAME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIE HAD A
MEAL AND THE GRANDDAUGHTER OF
THE TEACHER BARREN AND NIECE OF
MAURICIO BEREN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A BETWEEN.
VALERIE WITH SAID BECAUSE IN A
VERY SO BARREN JUNIOR.
HERE WITH YOU JUST AS COALITION.
AND OUR REALITIES I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE NINE TWO THANK
YOU.
THE LITTLE ECL YOU NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROUD RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO.
INSTRUCTS THE POOR.
MONEY ASSEMBLY MY NAME IS KEN
KELLER ON BEHALF OF MEN MAKING A
CHANGE I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB.
THREE NINE TWO I NAME IS JUDY
EVEN.
I'M HERE TO BE MY SON'S VOICE
JASON ALDERMAN.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE LET US
LIVE.
CHECK TARGET WITH THE ANTI
PLEASED HER PROJECT.
SPECTRUM AND SEGMENT LGBT
COMMUNITY AND THE STRONGER
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BRIDGET SERVE ALLEY
I'M AN INTERN WITH THE ACLU OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I SPENT THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS --
RESEARCHING OFFICER FATAL
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS WHERE
THEY SHOOT PEOPLE IN THE BACK
THAT ARE RUNNING AWAY AND LET ME
TELL YOU IT'S HORRIFYING IT
THERE ARE FULL OF CONTRADICTIONS --
FALSE STATEMENTS AND IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
NOT FACTUALLY.
MY NAME IS MAKAYLA MY NAME IS
MAKAYLA -- WHY DC [inaudible]
A SUPPORT [inaudible] TO HI MY
NAME IS THE ANGLE.
ON RELIGION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ALLEY I'M ALSO WITH
Y. G. SEEING I'M HERE FOR MY
BECAUSE IN JUNIOR RODRIGUEZ WHO
WAS FOURTEEN YEARS OLD SHOT AND
KILLED IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE I'M PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WE STRONG
SUPPORT.
ROSE MAYOR CHICAGO I'M WITH A
CAPITAL AREA MOMS DEMAND ACTION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M CYNTHIA SALAD
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE IN AMERICA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THERE'S CITY WHATEVER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY
CALIFORNIA.
EVEN WITH THIS BILL ALL ALONG WE
HAVE SOME RESERVATIONS ABOUT
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS TO
SATISFY THE POLICE HOWEVER WE
ARE STILL BE HAVE SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
AND WE HOPE THAT OUR OUR FEELS
ARE UNFOUNDED THANK YOU.
A QUICK Là PHILLIPS BEST SISTER
OF JASMINE PHILLIPS WHO WAS
MURDERED BY CHICO POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
MARCH -- SEVENTEENTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AM THEY SHOT
HIM. EIGHT TIMES WHILE HE WAS
DOWN I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE I DON'T WANT.
BASICALLY I HAVE KIDS OF MY OWN
AND I DON'T WANT THEM TO GO
THROUGH THIS I WANT.
TO SAVE ALL THESE KIDS LIKE THIS
IS RIDICULOUS I STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SO WE KEEPING DALY NIECE OF
MICHAEL.
DALY MURDER VICTIM OF A MASS
SHOOTING IN ELK GROVE MARCH.
TWO THOUSAND SIX HE WAS THE ONE
OF THE TARGETED VICTIMS AT
RANDOM OF A MASH SHOOTER WITH
SUICIDE BY COP WHITE SUPREMACIST
METH DEALER TRYING TO GET BACK
AT HIS WIFE WHO START EX WIFE.
THAT HE ABUSED.
AND TRYING TO RUIN HER LIFE BY
SHOOTING COPS SO HE FOUND A
PLACE WHERE COPS GO TO GET
DINNER AND SHOT PEOPLE AT RANDOM
IN ORDER. TO DIE.
AND HE WAS SHOT IN THE KNEE.
HE WAS SHOT MONEY SO WE ARE
MISUSING USE OF FORCE WHEN WE
ARE KILLING PEOPLE [inaudible]
FOR BUT REASONS FOR SENSELESS
REASONS AND YOU'RE LETTING
PEOPLE LIVE WHO ARE LITERALLY
MASH SHOOTERS.
THAT IS A PROBLEM WE HAVE TO DO
BETTER AND WE HAVE TO USE.
BETTER TRAINING BECAUSE WE HAD
TO GO ON A SIX YEAR TRIAL.
AND NOW HE'S GOING TO BE ON
DEATH ROW FOR FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
ACCORDING TO A SENTENCE SO
THAT'S NOT NECESSARY AND NONE OF
THIS IS NECESSARY SO.
FROM MY SIDE OF THE SPECTRUM DO
BETTER BE BETTER PASS THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NORMAN NELSON WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND BLACK WOMEN ORGANIZED FOR A
POLITICAL ACTION SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER.
OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA'S URGES YOU TO PASS
THIS BILL AND IS A VERY STRONG
SUPPORTER THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH RESULT IS PART
OF THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
NUMBER PERCENT IN.
MICHAEL NIDA KILLED OF TOWARD
TWENTY SECOND TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN FOR HIS FAMILY MEMBERS.
PLEASE PASS A. B. THREE NINE TWO
A WHOLE POLICE OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE [inaudible]
THANK.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THIS.
ONE HELLO MY NAME IS CHASING
KITCHEN IF I'M A CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE A DISTRICT FIVE A FEW
MONTHS AGO WHILE I WAS ENJOYING
A QUIET EVENING A YOUNG MAN WAS.
KILLED BY A SIX POLICE OFFICERS
IN A HAIL OF BULLETS I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
MARRYING HER NEW BROWN RESIDENT
OF THE LAYOVER WHERE -- WILLIE
MCCOY WAS KILLED SHOT FIFTY FIVE
TIMES WHILE SLEEPING IN THE CAR
LAST YEAR ON L. FOSTER WAS
KILLED DURING A ROUTINE TRAFFIC
STOP ON HIS BICYCLE WE'RE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ANGEL RAMOS
WAS KßT WAS SHOT BY POLICE.
IN A FISTFIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE MARIO ROMERO WAS --
SHOT THIRD TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
TIMES WHILE SITTING IN A CAR IN
FRONT OF HIS HOUSE I BEG YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA SMITH FROM
THE MOTHER SEES OUR CREWS WHO
WAS.
SHOT FIFTEEN TIMES IN THE BACK
WHILE STILL STRAPPED IN HIS SEAT
BELT DECEMBER ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR.
THAT I'M HERE.
NICE THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BEING SUCH A CHAMPION.
YOU HAVE BEEN.
AWESOME -- BUT THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR THAT I'M SPENDING MY
SON'S BIRTHDAY HERE.
SO THAT YOU CAN LET US LIVE SO
PLEASE LET US LIVE.
CURRENT HAMILTON OF THE ACLU
SACRAMENTO IN THE ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S JESS RODRIGUEZ ON
THE STOP COALITION HUCKLE
SPONSORING A BILL.
ARE MUCH TRONG SUPPORT -- ALSO A
IMPACTED FOUND REMEMBER MY
COUSIN JAMES GENERAL'S WAS
MURDERED BY ON HOW BIG THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HANNAH PLEASE PASS A BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LUCY AND I SUPPLY
A PT.
NINETY MY NAME IS GRETCHEN
ZIMMERMAN I'M A RESIDENT OF
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
POLICE ARE COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTROL AND NOT BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I AM NOW AFRAID TO CALL THE
POLICE FOR HELP BECAUSE I'M
AFRAID THEY'RE GOING TO KILL
SOMEBODY.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINETY TWO HI MY NAME IS
BARBARA OKAMOTO ON FROM STOP
COALITION MY GRANDSON
CHRISTOPHER OKAMOTO WAS MURDERED
ON AUGUST NINETEENTH. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ON A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THEY SHOT HIM EIGHT
TIMES THROUGH HIS SCREEN DOOR --
NEVER SAID ANYTHING JUST SHOT
HIM I TALKED TO HIM AT ELEVEN OO
TO AN ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHTY WAS
GONE PLEASE PASS THIS BILL SENT.
ANOTHER FAMILY DOESN'T HAVE TO
GO THROUGH WHAT WE GO THROUGH MY
SON SLEEPS ON THE FLOOR NEXT
ALWAYS LIKED.
MY GRANDSONS STUFF WAS PICTURES
EVERYTHING PLEASE PLEASE PASS
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I AM RACHEL GRANT I'M IN HERE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE WHOLE
FAMILY WHOSE SON MILES HALL WAS
KILLED LAST. TWO WEEKS AGO BY
ALONG THE CREEK PD.
ICE FULLY SUPPORT AB.
ONE THREE NINETY TWO HI MY NAME
IS -- JUICE LEBOW ODD LIKE TO
THANK -- DOCTOR WEBER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP -- REPRESENTED --
NAMI MARIN CHAPTER IT ALSO THE
COMMUNITY OF VALLEJO -- I HAVE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS STEVEN
MADERO'S AND I'M WITH THE ACLU
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINE TWO HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER -- HAAS I'M A RESIDENT
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINE TWO TOO MANY LIVES HAVE
BEEN LOST AND IT'S TIME TO PASS
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE ARE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE FAMILIES IN
THIS ROOM AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
MY NAME IS CARLOS MCCARTY WITH
STRONG SUPPORT.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME BY MORE OF
AN INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP FOR
PUBLIC ADDRESS WHEN SALINAS ALSO
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA LIES FOR
YOU THINK COMMUNITY JUSTICE AS
WELL AS THE LIVES OF WAS MANY
COLORS STRONG SUPPORT.
MORNING AND IS WORKING WITH A SO
YOU CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK A SPORT
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND FOR
THE OTHER BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR RHONDA
RENFRO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CLUB STRIDE INCORPORATED.
RESIDENT OF VALLEJO CALIFORNIA
ARE WE NEED.
WE URGE YOU TO PLEASE.
PASS THIS BILL.
YOUNG BLACK MEN IN THE CITY OF
VALLEJO ARE DYING.
THEY'RE DYING THE CITY OF
VALLEJO HAS LOS.
OUR OPPORTUNITIES. TO RECEIVE
INSURANCE BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE DYING.
SO I ASK YOU TO PLEASE PASS THIS
BILL I'M STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINETY TWO MY NAME IS
TERRENCE VADEN I'M FROM VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA -- I JUST THINK THAT
WHEN ANY ORGANIZATION OR GROUP
OF PEOPLE ARE DIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED BY THE COMMUNITY WITH
THE DEATH OF VIOLENCE OR
BRUTALITY -- SOME TEENS NEEDS TO
HAPPEN SO I SUPPORT THEM MAYBE
THEN INTO.
WHEN THE LUIS RESIDENT OF
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA WE NEED THIS
BILL IN OUR TOWN THANK YOU?
I YES -- DARYL EDWARDS FROM
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA.
MARTIN LUTHER KING SAID.
OUR ALLIES BEGIN THE IN.
WHEN WE BECOME SILENT ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT MATTER? ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT REALLY MATTERS TODAY
IS THAT THREE NINETY TWO MUST BE
CHANGED BECAUSE LIVES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED SO SEVERELY.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS -- AMENDMENT
OR BILL NEEDS TO BE PASSED BUT
BUT BILL NEEDS TO BE PASSED TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALSO.
BUT WE DEFINITELY NEED TO START
HERE TO MAKE A CHANGE NOW TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME'S STEVE ROGERS
WITH LAKE AVENUE CHURCH IN
PASADENA -- REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO FOR A
COMMUNITY AND WE'LL DO FOR STATE
AND DOCTOR ORIGINALLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COURAGE AND CONSISTENCY.
TO TO CONTINUE -- YOU KNOW
KEEPING UP THIS FIGHT AND YOU
KNOW HOPEFULLY THIS IS.
IS THE LAST TIME WE HAVE TO HAVE
THIS ARGUMENT.
THANKS.
GOOD MORNING PAUL THE ONE AND
JOHN PULLED THE ONE FROM LOS
ANGELES WERE ACLU MEMBERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT I WANTED TO THANK
YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
AND WE ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE
FROM ALL THE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
YES SOME AIR SUPPORT ADDRESSES
BUT THEN THE THING IS WE CAN
SAVE BAY LIES ARE NONE OF NONE
THE FAMILIES AS HERE.
BUT AS I BRING UP MY MY DAUGHTER.
I SINCE MY NEPHEW.
LET'S PUT SOME IN PLACE THAT IS
THAT A SAVE THEIR LIVES.
LET THEM LIVE GIVE HIM A CHANCE.
KEVIN'S CUT PROUD MEMBER THE
ACLU AN AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL I
URGE YOU TO TAKE TO HEART THE
SAD TRAGIC STORIES YOU HEARD
THIS MORNING PLEASE PASS THIS
BILL.
LUCIA KAISER RESIDENT OF DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND ACLU MEMBER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AB.
THREE NINE TWO CAN MORE UT W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY WEARE CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL -- LAST YEAR ARE -- NEEDED
TO BE MEMBER MEYER MICHAEL EASY --
WAS SHOT AND KILLED BY BUTTE
COUNTY POLICE.
AND WE'RE ON THIS BILL ALSO
BECAUSE NEARLY ONE THIRD TO A
HALF OF ALL PEOPLE KILLED BY
POLICE.
OUR FOLKS WITH DISABILITIES
MENTAL ILLNESS AS EVIDENCED ON
FRIDAY BY THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
SHOT KILLED BY OFF DUTY POLICE
OFFICER IN CORONA IN COSCO.
THAT MAN WAS NONVERBAL
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED HE'S
DEAD NOW AND HIS FAMILY WAS SHOT
AS WELL AND THAT OFFICER GOT TO
GO HOME AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KAI HEAVY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
UNITED OF JUSTICE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
AB THREE NINETY TWO BECAUSE MY
FAMILY HAS BEEN.
HURT BY THIS VIOLENCE PLEASE
PASS THIS BILL SO OF FAMILY DOES
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS AGAIN.
THE OTHER VEHICLE.
OF CSUS BEATRICE -- CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES UNITED FOR JUSTICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL NOW
AND THANK YOU DOCTOR SHIRLEY
WEBER AYE SHIRO.
THANK YOU.
I AM LUCKY TO DELLA ROSA THE
MOTHER JAMES DELLA ROSA THERE
WAS CAN'T BUY BACK TO POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS OR NOT OTHER
FAMILIES WILL BE. TO GO THROUGH
WHAT WE GO THROUGH ON A DAILY
BASIS BECAUSE IT IT'S NOT OVER
IT'S NOT OVER.
CHAD ANDREWS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY --
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE WORST
RATES OF FATAL OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS IN THE COUNTRY AT ITS
WORST AND AN EMBARRASSMENT IT'S
A TRAVESTY SOMETHING HAS TO BE
DONE.
WELL WE'RE CHEN AYE VOTE ON
THREE NINETY TWO WE ALSO URGE
EVERYBODY TO KEEP FIGHTING AFTER
IT PASSES.
THANK YOU -- EXCUSE ME HONORED
JUST MAKE A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT
ON ONE AND THOSE OF YOU IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO CONTINUE
AND GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY AND THEN
OF COURSE.
WE WILL CALL FOR IF THERE IS ANY
THIRTY ONE OPPOSITION BUT ONCE
WE HEAR THAT TESTIMONY.
WILL TAKE JUST A BRIEF FIVE
MINUTE RECESS AND SO MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAD TO GO DOWN TO ENERGY
TO VOTE INCLUDING MYSELF AND
THEN WE I'M GONNA GIVE THE MIKE
TO SENATOR JACKSON BUT WE'LL
JUST DO THE BRIEF RECESS.
SO THAT WE CAN.
UP APPROPRIATELY CONCLUDE THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL AND THAT
MY COLLEAGUES WHO I KNOW WOULD
WANT TO SPEAK TO IT CAN COME
BACK SO.
PLEASE CONTINUE I WILL GIVE THE
GAVEL TO SENATOR JACKSON AND
ONCE THE TESTIMONIES OVER WILL
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS TO MY
MEMBERS HAVE RETURNED.
AND THEN -- WE WILL HAVE OUR
APPROPRIATE DISCUSSION TO DO THE
PROPER JUSTICE TO THE DISCUSSION
ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND RARE RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THE LAST GUY ON BEHALF OF THE
HEART INSTITUTE IN THE PAN
AFRICAN GLOBAL INVESTOR
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
I MAY'VE MADISON AND I'M WITH
BAY PACK I DON'T WANNA THANK YOU
SHIRLEY WEBER. FOR YEAH ALL THE
BILLS THAT YOU HAVE ARE -- GIVEN
US BUT THIS ONE WE REALLY NEED.
AND I'M STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE THREE NINETY TWO I'M EUGENIA
MADISON AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THREE NINETY TWO MY NAME IS
IRVING ALVAREZ YOU THE JUSTICE
COALITION -- AND BROTHERS SONS
ITSELF COALITION HI SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU GIVE ME A JUSTICE
COALITION WERE HONORED TO BE
COSPONSORED ON THIS BILL.
I'M HERE TODAY FOR JONATHAN
QUICK US WHOSE FAMILY COULDN'T
BE HERE -- HE WAS KILLED IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN BY THE LA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S.
I HAVE TO SA JUST BRIEFLY THE
LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S AND ELLIE P.
LEADS THE NATION FOR MANY
DECADES IN USE OF FORCE
HOMICIDES.
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE THE HOMICIDE
RATE WAS TWICE AS MUCH.
THE OVERALL HOMICIDE BY USE OF
FORCE WAS 223% OF OUR DEATH
RATES IN LA COUNTY.
NOW WITH A 50% DECLINE IN
COMMUNITY HOMICIDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOMICIDES ARE UP IN
REAL NUMBERS AND IN A PERCENTAGE
NOW 628- PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE
KILLED IN LA COUNTY ARE KILLED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS AN EXCUSABLE AND HAVE TO
TALK STOCK [inaudible]
THANK YOU. SIX WITH THIS PLACE
HELLO ONE MOMENT RETIRED
MILITARY BETTER IN --
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
YOU NINE IT FOR JUSTICE.
DANIEL DAVENPORT -- I ECHO
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID ABOUT
THE THE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT YOU
KNOW BEING IN COMBAT BEING A WAR
IN OPERATION IRAQI FREEDOM -- TO
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT I
THOUGHT WAS A LITTLE WEIRD -- IN
REFERENCE AFTER I RE READ THIS.
IN REFERENCE BASICALLY WHAT I'M
SAYING IS MILITARY MEMBERS LIKE
WE SEE AN ENEMY WHO'S BEEN
KILLING PEOPLE AND WE CAN EVEN
PULL THE TRIGGER.
UNLESS THEY COME DOWN FROM THE
TOP WHICH I THINK IS IS WHILE
YOU KNOW TO ME I'M GOING TO PTSD
BECAUSE OF THAT.
YOU KNOW BUT THE POINT IS.
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE THAT HERE?
AND LONG STORY SHORT.
THERE'S A LOT OF TRAUMA ON THE
STREETS.
A LOT OF TRAUMA.
OFFICERS AS WELL AS AS CIVILIANS
I'M GOING TO GO BUT WHAT I WANT
TO SAY IS THIS.
IF POLICE OFFICERS ARE KILLING
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT'S NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GET THIS PASSED IN ONE OF THOSE
WAS NEXT.
IF THEY'RE KILLING PEOPLE WE
STILL WANT THEM TO BE ABLE.
TO FEED THEIR FAMILY BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE POLICE OFFICERS
THEY COULD BE TEACHERS WE HAVE
TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE AFTER
THIS PAST WE TAKE THE WEAPON
AWAY STILL PROVIDE ALTERNATE
MEANS FOR THEM TO FEED THE
FAMILY.
THEY CAN BE SOCIAL WORKERS THEY
CAN BE DOCTORS BUT BUT YOU WE'RE
IN SUPPORT YOU CAN'T BE KILLING
PEOPLE AND COME BACK AND KILL
SOMEBODY ELSE THAT'S STUPID.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WOULD COME FORWARD PLEASE.
LAST CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HEY I'M HERE TO SPEAK FOR AND
CORTEZ FOR SUN SENTINEL TREVINO
WAS SHOT AND KILLED IN LOS
ANGELES -- HE WAS SHOT.
BUT TWELVE OFFICERS A HUNDRED
FIFTY TIMES SEVENTY NINE HIT HIM
AND FIFTY EIGHT WERE FATAL.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT HE CALLED
THEM TO COME AND HELP HIM GET
THE STUFF THAT THEY HAD KICKED
HIM OUT.
AND THEY WOULD LET HIM HAVE A
STUFF AND HE CALLED.
AND THE OFF ONE OF THE GENTLEMAN
SAID HE HAS A GUN HE HAD A WHITE
PHONE IN HIS HAND.
AND HE WAS SHOT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TIMES.
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL FOR HIM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
OTHER WITNESSES VERY BRIEFLY
PLEASE IN SUPPORT.
NAME IS MOLLY WATSON I AM A
RESIDENT OF LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA WORK FOR COURAGE
CAMPAIGN WE'RE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER FOR ALL YOUR WORK AND WE
HOPE THIS GOES THROUGH.
THANK YOU PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE FOR THE FINAL
WITNESSES OF ARCHER FORMER FROM
WHY JC IS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
THANK YOU.
CAMERON MISSIONS DOES SUPPORTER
WHAT.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYESS SO DO WE WANT TO
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS AT THIS
POINT.
SHE SAID.
WELL I DON'T BELIEVE THERE IS
ANY.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION SO AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
DR WEBER WILL WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE WILL TAKE THAT BRIEF
BREAK SO THE PEOPLE CAN GO DOWN
AND VOTE AND THEN WE WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR DISCUSSION.
AT THAT POINT WERE IN A BRIEF
FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
HE WAS PERFECT SO.
WE WILL SHOULD.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND WAIT FOR
THE CHAIR.
AND BUT IF IF WE COULD WILL
START WITH WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR MITCHELL -- LET'S GO
AHEAD AND START WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL PLEASE -- DOCTOR WHERE
BROWN PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL WITH YOU AND WANT TO
ECHO ON THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MANY OF THE WITNESSES ON IN IN
IT NOW JEAN -- YOUR COURAGE AND
STEADFASTNESS ON WITH REGARD TO
THE BILL -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE OTHER
WILL YOU'VE ALSO PLAYED IN
GUARANTEEING THAT IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
THERE'S FUNDING FOR TRAINING --
AND SO WHILE INITIALLY -- THERE
WAS SOME CONCERN ABOUT.
JOINING YOUR BILL WITH THE
TRAINING BILL I THINK NOW -- THE
FINAL LEG THE THIRD LEG OF THE
STILL HAS BEEN ADDED AND SO
BETWEEN THE TWO BILLS -- AS WELL
AS FUNDING FOR THE TRAINING -- I
THINK THAT -- YOU AS WELL AS
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM SHOULD BE
VERY PROUD OF THE FINAL OUTCOME
THAT WAS A LONG TIME COMING.
BUT WE'RE HERE.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE POWER AND
STRENGTH OF THE COALITION THAT
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED YOU KNOW WE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO ARE USED TO
SING SOME OF THE USUAL SUSPECTS
PEOPLE WHO ARE -- WHAT I
CONSIDER GRASS TOPS ADVOCATES
WHO HAVE THE?
PLEASURE OF OF ARE YOU LIVING BY.
WORKING -- FOR JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS BUT TO SEE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION WHO COULD TAKE
THE BUS FROM LA IT'S GONNA BE A
HUNDRED DEGREES HERE TODAY --
AND THE CONSISTENCY WITH WHICH
PEOPLE HAVE SHOWN UP OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN I THINK IT'S
A POWERFUL TESTAMENT.
TO THE EMOTION IN THE REALITY OF
OF WHAT'S BEEN X. EXPRESSED BY
MANY OF THE FAMILY WITNESSES BUT
IN PARTICULAR THE MOTHERS.
A DOCTOR WHERE WERE YOU AND I
OFTEN HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
MOTHER IN AN EASY.
ALL AND I WAS REMINDED OF THAT
ONCE AGAIN TODAY BY.
THE WITNESSES WHO EXHIBIT SUCH
SHEER STRENGTH IN RECOUNTING FOR
US -- PAINFUL PAINFUL STORIES
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT IT
IS NOT.
IT MADE YOU ARE HEARD.
AND WE GET IT.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR
ENGAGE WITH IN THIS PROCESS AS
PAINFUL AS IT MAY BE.
IS TO INFORM US AS POLICY MAKERS
IN TERMS OF THE KINDS OF
DECISIONS WE HAVE TO MAKE EVERY
DAY ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. TO CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME ON AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND WITH THAT -- I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU -- THERE
IS A MOTION ANY FURTHER COMMENT
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU -- CENTER JACKSON --
OFFER SO DOT DOT DOT IRVINE.
DOCTOR OF I WANT.
TO I APOLOGIES ALLERGY SEASON --
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP BUT NOT SISTER
LEADERSHIP YOUR PERSISTENCE --
BECAUSE IT WAS A YEAR AGO THAT
WE WERE -- HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE -- AND I WAS PROUD TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF OF AB NINE
THIRTY ONE AS IT WAS CALLED AT
THAT TIME ALONG WITH OTHER
MEMBERS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE -- AND IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN LAST YEAR BUT YOU
KNOW -- YOU ARE -- TENACIOUS AND
COMING BACK AND NOT LETTING IT
GO AND THE COALITION WAS NOT
ABOUT TO LET IT GO THANKFULLY --
AND AND HERE WE ARE AND I KNOW
IT HASN'T BEEN EASY AND THERE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE DISAGREEMENTS
ABOUT NEGOTIATIONS -- BY HI THIS
IS STILL A VERY STRONG BILL --
THAT WILL SAVE LIVES AND SO I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT TODAY.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY TO SOME OF
THE FAMILIES WHO CAME OUT AND I
KNOW I MADE THESE COMMENTS.
WHEN -- WE HEARD SB TWO THIRTY A
FEW MONTHS AGO -- THAT HIGH - I
CANNOT EVEN BEGIN TO COMPREHEND
WHAT IT IS WHAT IT MUST BE LIKE
TO HAVE TO BIRD AND I SAID TO
HAVE TO BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
COMPELLED TO TELL TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED -- IN THE NAME OF
JUSTICE -- AND I TO TO COME OUT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST TIME TO ANY OF
THESE FAMILIES OF COURSE HAS.
SPOKEN PUBLICLY -- ABOUT -- THE
TRAGEDY THAT THAT THE THE THE
THE HORROR OF WHAT HAPPENED --
AND TO TALK ABOUT THAT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AB I KNOW EVERY TIME
IT.
IT'S JUST I I CAN I CAN EVEN
IMAGINE -- I DON'T WANT TO THANK
ALL THE FAMILIES -- THAT HAVE
BEEN WILLING -- TO IN JUROR THAT
PAIN OVER AND OVER AGAIN -- IN
THE NAME OF MAKING POSITIVE
CHANGES IN CALIFORNIA SO I'M
HAPPY.
TO I SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
BETTER BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I TO WANNA CALL THE
SENTIMENTS OF MUCH WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HERE AT THE MOMENT
MOST IMPORTANTLY WHAT.
THE WITNESSES HAVE SAID TODAY
AND WHAT YOU SAID -- REALIZE
YEAR. TO BRING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND TO THE TREMENDOUS
COURAGE THAT DOCTOR WEBER HAS
SHOWN AND I'M HONORED TO BE.
A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
BUT I MOVED TO THE FACT THAT.
WE REALLY DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
RACE.
AND THAT'S AT THE CORE OF WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE OF WE UNDERSTAND THE
ORIGIN.
OF THE USE OF DEADLY FORCE IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO IT WAS IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO FREE AFRICANS
AND IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT WAS NO GREATER THREAT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO THEN IT WAS.
IN.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE WAS BLOCKS WERE FREE
AND THIS WAS A WAY OF
SUPPRESSING PEOPLE AND WE'VE
SEEN THROUGHOUT HISTORY WHETHER
IT'S AN OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
WHETHER IT'S IN OUR HOUSING
WHETHER TíNH JOBS IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
RACE IS ALWAYS THE COURT AND IT
DEMONSTRATES ITSELF MORE IN
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY AND WE
SEE IT HERE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AT I GREW UP IN A WHITE
COMMUNITY AND I SAW THE
INTERACTION THAT WAS DIFFERENT
BETWEEN MY WIFE FRANCE WHEN IT
CAME LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WHEN IT
CAME TO PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKEME.
AND IT WAS A STARK DIFFERENCE
AND I REMEMBER A HEARING WE HAD.
AN ASSEMBLY WHEN I CHAIR TO SLOT
COMMITTEE ON BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
AND WE HAD A POLICE CHIEF.
AND THAT HEARING THAT.
AFTERNOON [inaudible]
AND WE WERE ASKING ABOUT SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES OF DEALING WITH.
YOUNG BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
AND HE STOPPED FOR A MOMENT ANY
SAYS THE HARDEST DAY OF MY LIFE
WAS WHEN MY SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SON
GOT HIS DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND I HAD TO SIT HIM DOWN AND
EXPLAIN WHAT HE SHOULD DO NOT IF
HE STOPPED BY THE POLICE BUT
WHEN HE STOPPED BY THE POLICE.
THIS INDIVIDUAL WAS A BLACK
POLICE CHIEF ANY SAYS MY WHITE
COUNTERPARTS DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION WITH THEIR KIDS.
SO WE NEED TO TELL THE TRUTH
HERE TODAY AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THE CORE.
TRAINING WILL NOT CHANGE
PEOPLE'S HEART WE HAVE TO CHANGE
OUR VIEW AS IT RELATES TO RACE
IN THIS COUNTRY AND UNDERSTAND
IT'S AT THE CORE OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S BAD HERE.
WE WERE FOUNDED ON RACISM AND
WE'VE IN SLAVE THE BLACK PERSON
WE EXPLOIT IT THE BROWN AND
YELLOW PEOPLE.
AND WE HAD TRIED TO ANNIHILATE
TO READ MAN AND WE HAVE TO
ACCEPT IT FOR WHAT IT IS SO.
UNTIL WE CAN CHANGE.
THE HEART OF PEOPLE THEY OFTEN
SAY WHY DO BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE RUN FROM FROM THE POLICE.
THEY FEAR THE POLICE.
AND YOU CAN NEVER RESPECT AND
TRUST ANYTHING OR ANYONE THAT
YOU FEAR.
SO UNTIL WE CAN REMOVE THAT FEAR
FACTOR WE'RE GOING TO STILL HAVE
THESE CHALLENGES.
AND YOU CAN'T PROTECT.
AND SERVE AND TO YOU RESPECT AND
PRESERVE LIFE.
SENATOR JACKSON IS THANK YOU AND
I APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THOSE
ELOQUENT IN AND ACCURATE SADLY
ACCURATE REMARKSABOUT OUR
NATION WHICH TODAY IS BECOMING
EVEN MORE.
DIVIDED -- YOU MENTIONED RACE
AND ETHNICITY AND AND RELIGION
IT'S IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT AND WE HAVE TO DO MUCH BETTER.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
ADDITIONAL ASPETS THAT I JUST
WANTED.
TO BRING. TO THE FORE IS THE
SORT OF THE PARAMILITARY NATURE.
OF HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT NOW VIEWS
ITSELF REALLY RATHER THAN AS
COMMUNITY INTERVENE ORDERS -- AS
AS A PARALEGAL MILITARY
OPERATION.
AND I THINK OF IN MY HOPE IS
THAT WITH THIS TRAINING.
WE WILL GO BACK OR OR CANYON
SINGLE BACK THAT WE WILL
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT --
TRUST IN PROTECT ASPECT OF WHAT
POLICING IS AT LEAST
THEORETICALLY SUPPOSED TO BE.
A PROTECTING THE PUBLIC -- BUT I
THINK IN TODAY'S WORLD WE LACK
THAT ELEMENT OF COMPASSION.
WE LACKED THAT ELEMENT OF TRYING
TO INTERVENE EFFECTIVELY.
AND RATHER THAN JUST ASSUME THAT
THE ONLY WAY TO RESOLVE THE
PROBLEM IS WITH A GUN.
WE HAVE TO REALIZE THAT THERE
ARE OTHER IN MUCH BETTER WAYS TO
DO THIS.
AS WE'VE LEARNED -- ABOUT THE
BRAIN AS WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT
MENTAL ILLNESS.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL APPLY THE
TECHNIQUES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE
MANY OF WHOM AND AS LISTENING TO
THE THE HEARTFELT AND AND GUT
WRENCHING STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO
LOST LOVED ONES.
MANY OF THEIR LOVED ONES HAVE
BEEN IN CRISIS WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH PTSD WHETHER IT'S JUST
SIMPLE FEAR -- THAT MAKES PEOPLE
REACT RATHER THAN BE RATIONAL.
I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I SUSPECT THAT'S
PART OF WHAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBBER'S EFFORT
IS HERE IS TO GET US TO USE THE
BUILT ALL THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
TO TRY TO DE ESCALATE THESE
PROCEEDINGS BEFORE THEY BECOME --
OF VIOLENCE AND BEFORE -- THEY'D
THE RESULT IN THE DEATHS IN THE
SERIOUS INJURY TO PEOPLE THAT
ARE PROBABLY OTHERWISE
AFFORDABLE SO I TO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT -- THAT
YOU'VE DONE A DOCTOR WEBER THIS
STRUCTURE IS NOT BEEN EASY.
I AM SO PLEASED THAT THERE WAS
NO OPPOSITION HERE TODAY IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'VE MADE PROGRESS
IT'S NOT PERFECT.
BUT I THINK IF WE START FOCUSING
ON INTERVENTIONS -- RATHER THAN.
THE DEADLY FORCE I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO REALLY CHANGE.
OUR COMMUNITIES AND DO SO FOR
THE BETTER SO I ALSO SUPPORT THE
pAND WILL BE HAPPY TO VOTE.
FOR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
FEAR GOOD COMMENTS AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER.
INCREDIBLE RESPECT FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE.
AND YOUR WILLINGNESS.
TO HANG IN THERE.
AND CONTINUE THIS SUCH IMPORTANT.
POLICY DEBATE.
AND MOVEMENT ON A VERY NEEDED
POLICY AND I JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU ALL KUDOS FOR THAT.
AND I WANT TO ALSO EXPRESS --
KUDOS FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SIT DOWN AND ENGAGE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH WE WOULD
LOOKED LIKE WE WERE MAYBE AT A
SITUATION.
WHERE -- THOSE DISCUSSIONS WERE
EITHER WERE NOT HAPPENING OR
PERHAPS WERE PRODUCTIVE AND SO I
WANTED BOTH THINK LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR ENGAGING.
WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE IN YOUR
AND YOUR BILL SPONSORS AND ALSO
YOU FOR THAT WILLINGNESS THAT
HAS BROUGHT US TO THIS SITUATION
TODAY WHERE WE HAVE A BILL
BEFORE US WITH NO OPPOSITION.
SO -- JUST RESPECTING KUDOS AND
THEN I ALSO WANTED TO EXPRESS TO
ALL OF YOU WHO ARE HERE.
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT ON THE
ONE HAND I HOPE THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO COME BACK.
AND RELIVE THE TRAUMA BY
DISCUSSING YOUR LOVED ONE'S
DEATH FOR OTHER PEOPLE YOU KNOWS --
DEATH.
ON THE OTHER HAND I HOPE THAT
YOU DO COME BACK BECAUSE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND YOUR PERSISTENCE
HAS MATTERED.
AND IT HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE.
IT HAS ENABLED THIS DISCUSSION
TO CONTINUE TO BE HONEST AND TO
BE VERY FORTHRIGHT.
AND AS WE DEVELOP PUBLIC POLICY
AS LEGISLATORS WE NEED THE
ENGAGEMENT OF THE AFFECTED
PARTIES AND SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND YOUR WILLINGNESS TO REALLY
DEAL WITH SUBJECTS THAT ARE.
HEART BREAKING AND DIFFICULT BUT
AS A POLICY CHANGE SO NEEDED --
AND THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
FOR YOUR VERY STRONG COMMENTS I
THINK THERE ARE MANY MANY
FACTORS THAT.
WHETHER IT'S THE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE ON EITHER BODY CAMERAS OF
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
ALL OF US WITH THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE ON OUR PERSON AT ALL TIMES
THE ABILITY TO TAKE VIDEOS.
THERE'S SO MANY FACTORS THESE
THOSE VIDEOS OF THESE INCIDENTS
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION THAT
HAS BEEN UNDER WAY FOR SOME TIME
MANY MANY OTHER THINGS.
THAT HAVE BEEN ENABLED US. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE ROOT OF SO
MANY PROBLEMS THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO CORRECT.
HIS RACISM.
AND IT IS ALLOWED I THINK SO
MANY MORE PEOPLE TO SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY TO THAT FACT.
AND WE ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE GOT A GREAT HISTORY
LESSON FROM OUR COLLEAGUE
SENATOR BRADFORD YESTERDAY ABOUT
THE SODA BIG RED AND WHILE I WAS
FAMILIAR WITH THAT SODA.
I DIDN'T REALLY KNOW ANY HISTORY
OF IT REFLECTING THE BLOODSHED
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS AS SLAVES
ONCE FREED AND UNFORTUNATELY --
CONTINUING TODAY SO IT'S THE
DISCUSSION THE PUBLIC DISCUSSION
AROUND THESE MATTERS AND OUR
ABILITY AND WILLINGNESS TO SPEAK
TRUTHFULLY AND DIRECTLY.
I THINK ADVANCES THE POLICIES
THAT ALL OF US ARE ENGAGED IN
TRYING TO MAKE.
SO I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
AND AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR.
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A MOTION.
YES I WOULD BE UPGRADE THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL -- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU.
AND PROVIDING THE TESTIMONY
CONCERNING -- THE USE OF LETHAL
FORCE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I TRULY HAVE TO THANK THE
PARENTS AND THE VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ENTRUSTED
THEIR FAITH IN ME. TO CARRY THIS
BILL FORD.
AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TAUGHT ME SO
MUCH.
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF NOT
ONLY HAVE I EXPERIENCED AND FELT
YOUR HURT IN YOUR PAIN.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT YOUR
PERSISTENCE.
I WAS ASKED BY ONE MEDIA PERSONS
IS WHY YOU EXPENDING SUCH
POLITICAL CAPITAL ON THIS BILL.
AND I HAD TO REMIND THEM WHO
GAVE ME THE CAPITAL.
IT'S THE COMMUNITIES THAT I SIR
AND I'VE ALWAYS SERVED WHO GAVE
ME THE CAPITAL AND IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE THAT
CAPITAL IN THEIR BEST INTEREST.
AND I WAS ON IT HONOR TO
BASICALLY BE ABLE TO CARRY THIS
BILL FORWARD.
SOMEONE ASKED ME.
WHY ARE YOU FIGHTING SO HARD?
AND I SAID I'VE BEEN BLACK ALL
MY LIFE.
AND A PART OF THAT IS THE
ABILITY TO FIGHT.
BUT IF I STAND TODAY AT THIS
POINT IN MY LIFE AT THIS AGE.
IT IS BECAUSE I'VE LEARNED HOW
TO STAND AND HOW TO BE
PERSISTENT.
AND THE FIGHT FOR MY PLACE IN
YOUR PLACE IN THIS WORLD.
SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UTILIZE ALL OF
THE POLITICAL CAPITAL THAT YOU
GAVE ME.
KNOWING THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO GIVE ME THAT CAPITAL.
AND THAT IT WOULD NEVER BE
EXPENDED.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES WHO CAME FORWARD
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE.
AND THE DIVERSITY OF THE PAIN
THAT WAS SHOWN HERE.
SO OFTEN WE ONLY THINK IT'S
BLACK AND BROWN.
BUT YOU SEE EVERYONE IS AFFECTED
BY THE VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENS IN
THIS NATION.
AND PARTICULARLY IN THE STATE.
AND THAT IN ITSELF IS
HEARTWARMING BECAUSE EVERY TIME
WE'VE CALL THEY'VE BEEN HERE TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY THINK NEEDS
TO HAPPEN AND THEIR FAITH IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE BELIEF IN CALIFORNIA THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER.
I WANT TO THANK THE POLICE
OFFICERS AND POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATIONS WHO -- WERE
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
BROUGH RECENTLY SAT DOWN AND WE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR CONCERN.
AND THEY'RE CONCERNED THAT WITH
ABLE TO BE JUDGED ON HINDSIGHT
WHICH WAS NOT WHAT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL WAS.
I MADE CLEAR TO THEM IN THE VERY
BEGINNING THAT THIS BILL WAS NOT
TO BE A GOT TO BE ALL.
THIS IS A BILL TO PREVENT DEATH.
AND TO PROVIDE SAFETY FOR
OFFICERS AND COMMUNITIES.
I HAD TO EXPLAIN TO THEM THAT I
WANT TO COMMUNITY THAT WHERE I
CAN CALL POLICE OFFICERS WHEN I
HAVE DIFFICULTY.
AND KNOW THAT THE SITUATION WILL
BE BETTER AND NOT WORSE.
I WANT TO SHE I WHAT I DID NOT
WANT TO HAVE TO SIT AND TELL THE
STORY.
THAT MODE WAS TOLD TO MY BROTHER.
AND MY UNCLES AND MY GRANDFATHER
ABOUT INTERACTION WITH PLEASE.
I DON'T WANT TO TELL THAT STORY
TO A KEY TO COULD DEAR AND JULIE
ALL.
MY FIVE AND SEVEN YEAR OLD
GRANDSON'S.
I WANT THEM TO LIVE IN THE WORLD
THAT THEY THINK THEY LIVE IN
RIGHT NOW.
WHICH IS ONE THAT IS WONDERFUL
WITH THEIR FRIENDS OF ALL KINDS
OF OF RACE AND AND GENDER.
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE JUDGED
FAIRLY AND JUSTLY ON PLAYGROUND
WHEN THEY HAVE DIFFICULTY?
THAT'S THE WORLD THEY DESERVE
AND THAT'S THE WORLD THAT I MUST
GIVE TO THEM AFTER FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS OF STRUGGLING IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR JUST SIMPLE JUSTICE
AND EQUALITY AND TO BE TREATED
FAIRLY.
SO I SIMPLY WANT TO SAY THAT I
AM HONORED TO CARRY THIS BILL.
HONOR TO DEMONSTRATE WHAT MY
MOTHER AN MY GRANDMOTHER AND MY
GREAT GREAT GRANDMOTHER'S OF
ALWAYS TAUGHT ME ABOUT THE
STRENGTH OF BLACK WOMEN.
BUT WE ARE THE MULES OF THE
WORLD.
THAT WE CARE THE BURDEN THAT
NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO KERRY.
AND I'M PROUD TO BE THAT NEW FOR
YOU.
AB THREE NINE TWO IS A NECESSARY
STEP IN AFFIRMING THE SANCTITY
OF LIFE AND PROTECTING HUMAN
RIGHTS.
AND WE HAVE GONE TOO MANY DAYS
FAR ALONG WITH TOO MANY DEATHS.
BECAUSE OF OUR OWN ACTIONS AND
THOSE WHO HAVE THE POWER TO
ENACT CHANGE THAT IS CRITICAL.
THE NEED FOR REFORM IS CLEAR.
AND IT IS LONG OVERDUE.
I WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR.
I WANT TO THANK MY PRESIDENT PRO
TEM HERE IN THE SENATE MY GOOD
FRIEND WHO PROMISED TO BRING
THIS BILL BACK.
I DON'T THINK THE SPEAKER MISTER
RENDON FOR HIS COURAGE ND
SIGNING ON TO THIS BILL. FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS HOUSE IS
FINALLY SAY IT TIME IS UP.
TIME IS UP FOR INJUSTICE.
TIME IS JUST RIGHT FOR US TO
HAVE A STATE WHY POLICY THE
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION.
BUT HOW WILL HAVE A POLICY THAT
RESPECTS THE SAME TO T. OF LIFE.
THAT WOULD TRAIN ITS OFFICERS TO
BASICALLY ENGAGE IN DE
ESCALATION STRATEGIES.
THAT WILL NOT MAKE THEM AT HARM
BUT BASICALLY MAKE THEM SAFE AS
WELL AS OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND FOR THAT REASON AND ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THE CO AUTHORS
AND ALL THE THE WORK THOSE OF
YOU WHO WORK SO HARD FOR THE
LAST YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL
TO AB.
THREE NINE TWO BUT SOME CALL THE
ROLL THE BILL IS -- DO PASS. TO
THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SKINNER.
HI I'M MORE LIKE.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
WIENER WIENER AYE.
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPENING
CASE OR ABSENT MEMBER -- RETURNS
BUT I THINK YOU'RE IN GOOD SHAPE.
AND THANK YOU ALL
.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
WE HAVE -- THREE BILLS OF YEARS.
AND MAYBE WE'LL WAIT JUST A
MOMENT IF THERE'S IF YOU HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOR THIRTEEN THEY CAN COME TO
THE TABLE OR OTHERWISE LINE UP
THE MIKE.
BECAUSE WILL START WITH ITEM TEN
AB.
FOR THIRTEEN AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S --
EXCITEMENT ABOUT THE COMMITTEES
ACTION ON THREE NINE TWO BUT I
HOPE THAT -- IF YOU WANT TO HEAR
THIS NEXT BILL THAT WE'RE ABOUT
TO HEAR PLEASE.
TAKE YOUR SEATS AND IF NOT IF
YOU WANT TO JUST.
TALK TO YOUR COLLEAGUES OUTSIDE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT SO WE COULD
CONTINUE THE HEARING.
THANKS SO MUCH WE DO NEED TO
CONTINUE SO THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
TALKING IF YOU COULD STEP
OUTSIDE THAT WOULD BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
AB PORTANTINO CHANGES REFERENCES
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRPERSON THE MEMBERS -- AB
FOR THIRTEEN CHANGES RECTUS IS
UP AT RISK TO AT PROMISE IN
EDUCATION IN PENAL CODES AT RISK
IS A STIGMATIZED LABELS THAT
CREATES AN EXPECTATION OF
FAILURE.
AND FOCUSES ON THE LIKELIHOOD OF
USE BECOMING ANOTHER STATISTIC.
THIS IS A MINDSET THAT IS ALL
TOO PERVASIVE IN OUR SCHOOLS
COMMUNITIES AND JUSTICE SYSTEM
PERCEPTION MATTERS.
AND ARE USED ARE MORE THAN THEIR
SITUATION ENDING THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE START WITH HOW
WE TREAT OUR YOUTH.
AND BE A MORE INTENTIONAL WITH
OUR LANGUAGE AB -- FOR THIRTEEN
TRANSITIONS CALIFORNIA TO THE
STRENGTH BASED APPROACH AT
PROMISE IT RECOGNIZES THE
POTENTIAL OF EVERY STUDENT TO
SUCCEED. FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IS ERNIE SO
VOTE FOR SIDE TECH AND PAM GIVES
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
[inaudible]
OF EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR SEAT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I'M MONEY SO IF I WORK FOR
CYTOTEC WERE AND NETWORK OF
OPPORTUNITIES WE ENGAGEMENT --
SCHOOLS WE USE THIS IDEA THAT
PROMISE AS A AS A STRATEGY AND
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
BILL TO PROVIDE A PLATFORM IN.
CODE I JUST WANT TO SHARE A
QUICK STORY ABOUT TWO OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO GRADUATED ON
THIS PAST THURSDAY JUNE
THIRTEENTH.
DEVON JOSEPH ARE.
BOTH HAD DROPPED OUT OF
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS THEY HAD
BEEN ABANDONED BY THEIR DRUG
ADDICTED PARENTS AND WERE RAISED
BY THEIR GRANDMOTHER.
DAVID DROPPED OUT OF OF SCHOOL
TO WORK TO SUPPORT HIS
GRANDMOTHER AND HIS YOUNGER
BROTHER -- WHEN HE CAME TO US
SEE -- WE WE'VE HELPED FOCUS ON
PROMISE HELPED HIM PUT A RESUME
TOGETHER HELP THEM WORK ON
INTERVIEW SKILLS AND HELP THEM
FIND A PART TIME JOB WITH HIS
FOCUS ON PROMISED DAVIS DAVIS
CONFIDENCE SOARED.
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED HIS --
SCHOOL WORK AND HELD THE JOB THE
WHOLE TIME HE WAS AT SCIENTIFIC.
EARNED HIS CREDITS TO GRADUATE
IS ALREADY APPLIED FOR
EMPLOYMENT WITH THE POLICE FORCE
IN SAN DIEGO.
IN JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN DAVID
BROUGHT HIS BROTHER JOSEPH TO
ENROLL IN SCIENTIFIC DOES IF IT
STOPPED GOING TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
OF BULLYING DUE TO HIS LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
HE RESPONDED WELL TO THE AT
PROMISED FOCUS ON THE STRAINS
COMPLETE IS -- HIGH SCHOOL
CREDITS AND FOCUS ON COLLEGE
PREPARATION HE BE HILL BEGIN --
CLASSES AT SAN DIEGO CITY
COLLEGE IN THE FALL WITH AN
INTEREST IN BIOLOGY HE'S JUST
ACCEPTED A PAID INTERNSHIP WITH
THE YOUTH CONSERVATION CORPS
WORKING WITHIN THE US FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE.
AT THE SAN DIEGO WILDLIFE REFUGE
HIS CAREER GOALS TO BECOME A
DOCTOR THE APP PROMISE APPROACH
THAT WE USE AND SCHOOLS AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE YOU
INCREASINGLY USING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I'M CHANGE THESE YOUNG MEN'S
LIVES -- WE WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A BEFORE.
THIRTEEN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT A BEFORE
THIRTEEN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIDGET JONES SAWYER IS EFFORTS
OVER THE YEARS. TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN THAT WE FIND OUT
PROMISE. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
LAKE TAHOE IS PROUD OF IS THE
FACT THAT WE SERVE CHILDREN WHO
FACE NUMEROUS CHALLENGES.
THERE EITHER INCARCERATED THEY
HAVE FACED NUMEROUS SITUATIONS
OF TRAUMA AND WE WORK VERY HARD
TO ADDRESS FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESS
YOUTH -- AND OTHERS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
IT CHANGES THE COLD AND THEY'RE
BY CHANGING OUR LANGUAGE.
CAN PERMEATE MANY OF THE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES OF THE PROGRAM'S
REFERENCED IN THE EDUCATION AND
PENAL CODE SYSTEM THAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOU.
WE THINK THAT IN TURN WILL HELP
US AS WE VOLUNTEER AND SERVE OUR
YOUTH WILL CHANGE OUR LANGUAGE
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
PERCEPTION OF THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES.
SO BEING OUT PROMISE WHEN THEY
ATTEND A PROGRAM OR SOME KIND OF
EVENTS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE OF WORKING
WITH NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS AND
HAVE WAS OF FOUND.
A VERY DISMAYED BECAUSE I
PARTICIPATED IN A PROGRAM WHERE
THERE WAS A FLYER THAT REFERENCE
THE CHILDREN AS AT RISK OF WHEN
THEY CAME TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM.
AND SINCE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THIS BILL OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I THOUGHT ABOUT HOW I WOULD FEEL
IF I WALKED INTO AN AUDITORIUM
AND A FLYER EXPRESSING THE
PROGRAM SAID.
THIS IS TO BENEFIT AT RISK YOUTH
AND I THOUGHT.
WOULDN'T IT BE WONDERFUL IF THE
FLYERS SAID WERE BENEFITING AT
PROMISE YOUTH.
SO FOR THAT REASON AND FOR THE
REASON THAT WE WANT CHILDREN TO
SEE THEMSELVES AS PROMISING WE
OR DRIVE VOTE FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU.
RIGHT TO HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE SIX DOLLAR SIGN.
KAELIN DEAN FROM THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR -- IN
PROUD SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME BY IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT TO WEAR MANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NONE -- OUR
COMMENTS ARE MOTION I SENATOR
BRADFORD.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS COMMONSENSE APPROACH
AND THE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS
OF THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT IS
THE STIGMATIZING A TITLE OR
LABEL THAT YOU PUT ON CHILDREN
WHEN YOU STAY.
AT REST AND USUALLY THE FOLKS
ONCE AGAIN WE'RE DONE A FINER
USUALLY POOR IN PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND IT WHICH DONDE ME A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHEN SOMEONE SIR WELL
RICH KID TERRORISTS.
TO OF TAKING A PORSCHE PARENTS
PORSCHE.
GETTING A GOLD CARD IN GOING
CHARGING SOMETHING UP -- GETTING
INTO MATTERS MEDICINE CABINET
AND TAKING THEIR DRUGS SO YES SO
I THINK.
THE TERM AT PROMISE A COVERS
EVERYBODY SO AND I COMMEND YOU
FOR THAT AND I WOULD LOVE THE
ACTORS CO AUTHOR [inaudible]
MORE [inaudible]
I'M.
WE'VE GOT THE MOTION AND OF OF
IT'S TO PASS THE FLOOR BUT
OBVIOUSLY WILL YOU YOU CAN BOTH
TALK BECAUSE THERE MAY BE THE
ABILITY TO DO AN AMENDMENT
BEFORE COSTA FLOOR BUT THAT A
LEAF WITH YOU ALL TO FIGURE OUT --
AND I'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION.
OTHERWISE -- SOME REMEMBER YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BOTH
EXCELLENT WAS TO ROLL CALL.
SKINNER.
HI THERE I MORE LACK.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL.
MORALE.
WIENER I'VE WIENER I I WILL --
KEEP THE BILL ON CALL AND WILL
ALLOW YOU TO GO TO YOUR NEXT
ITEM WHICH IS FIFTEEN A. B.
[inaudible]
NINE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AB NINE TWENTY SEVEN REVISED ITS
STATE LAW BY REQUIRING A
DEFINING OF A DEFENDANT'S
ABILITY TO PAY PRIOR TO THE
ASSESSMENT OF A FINER FEE.
IN CALIFORNIA BOTH THE
GOVERNMENT AND PENAL CODE
CONTAINS SECTIONS THAT REQUIRE
THE COURT TO ASSESS FINES AND
FEES ON CRIMINAL.
DEFENDANTS DEFINES RECESS
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY.
FUNDS RECEIVED PROVIDE MONEY FOR
AT LEAST FIFTY DIFFERENT STATE
AND LOCAL PROGRAMS AS IDENTIFIED
BY THE LA OWES OFFICE.
THIS EFFECTIVELY CREATES A SET
FOR DEBT FUNDS COURTS STATE
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL NEEDS ON
THE BACKS OF POOR PEOPLE.
THERE IS OVER TEN BILLION
BILLION WOULD BE AN OUTSTANDING
V. AND FIND IT IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD CLEARLY SHOWS THAT WE ARE
OVER RELIANCE ON ON COLLECTIBLE
FINES.
FROM POOR DEFENDANTS IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
THESE HEFTY FINES ARE OFTEN
LEVIED ON A POOR.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOLLOWING THE
WORK DONE BY THE COMMISSION ON
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA COURT
SYSTEM HAS BEEN WORKING ON A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW
DEFENDANTS TO SEEK REDUCED OR
WAIVED FEES FOR TRAFFIC FINES.
TRAFFIC FINES MAKE UP TWO THIRDS
OF CURRENT ASSESS PARTS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
REMAINING THIRD THE FINES LEVIED
AFTER MISDEMEANOR FELONY THIS
BILL DOES THREE THINGS FIRST.
IT FLIPS THE PRESUMPTION ABILITY
TO PAY FROM THE DEFENDANT TO THE
PROSECUTION REQUIRING THEM TO
SHOW AN ABILITY TO PAY WHEN THAT
IS IN QUESTION SECOND CREATES A
PRESUMPTION.
THAT THE HOMELESS THOSE ARE NEED
SPACE ASSISTANCE THOSE MEETING
THE DEFINITION OF VERY LOW
INCOME AND THOSE SENTENCED TO
LENGTHY SENTENCES ARE UNABLE TO
PAY.
FINALLY ESTABLISH A SYSTEM OF
FACTORS FOR COURTS TO CONSIDER
WHEN EVALUATING ABILITY TO PAY
INCLUDING WHETHER OR NOT THE
DEFENDANT HAD A PUBLIC DEFENDER.
THIS BILL IS IN LINE WITH RECENT
COURT RULINGS IN THIS AREA THE
SECOND COURT OF APPEALS IN
CALIFORNIA HELD THE IMPOSING
FINES WITH OUT AN ASSESSMENT OF
ABILITY TO PAY WAS A VIOLATION
OF DUE PROCESS.
THE SUPREME COURT ALSO NOTED
THAT EXCESSIVE FINES ARE THREAT
TO CIVIL LIBERTIES AND RECENT
THAMES PURSES INDIANA CASE.
THIS IS A BALK WILL BUILD THAT
BOUNCES CIVIL LIBERTIES COURT.
WORKLOAD AND FUNDAMENTAL SENSE
OF FAIRNESS MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT WITH ME TODAY IS MARCO
GEORGE THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
OF COURSE MARKET.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
I AM HONORED TO BE ASKED TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL AND
I APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MMBER.
REGINALD JONES SAWYER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER ALL TOO OFTEN I SAW
FIRST HAND THE HARMFUL EFFECTS
OF AND PAID FINES AND FEES ON
THE LIVES OF MY CLIENTS.
A MANY TIMES SAY FACED
ADDITIONAL INCARCERATION FOR
FAILURE TO PAY.
WHICH ALSO COST THE COMMUNITY
AND THE TAXPAYERS -- TO TO HOUSE
THEM.
THERE WERE FINANCIAL BURDENS ON
THEIR FAMILIES.
THERE WAS AN INABILITY TO
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE AND TO
THE COMMUNITY -- MANY OF THEM
FACED HOMELESSNESS THE PROSPECT
OF EITHER PAYING.
UNREALISTIC FINES AND FEES ARE
BEING HOMELESS OR PAYING THE
RENT.
AND AN ALL TOO MANY CASES PEOPLE
ONCE THEY WERE UNABLE TO PAY THE
FINES OR FEES WARRANTS WERE
ISSUED AND THEY WERE RETURNED TO
JAIL BECOMING A BURDEN ON THE
TAXPAYERS.
THE FINES AND FEES HAVE BEEN
PART OF FINANCING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ON THE BACKS OF
THE POOR AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THE SENATE SYSTEM PERVERSE
INCENTIVES ACROSS THE BOARD.
COURTS -- INCREASED FEES TO PAY
FOR THE COURT SYSTEM AND
PROBATION OFFICERS WHO SHOULD BE
TASKED WITH HELPING PEOPLE RE
INTEGRATE INTO THE COMMUNITY
BECOME BILL COLLECTORS.
I WOULD ECHO THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMENTS ABOUT THE SUPREME COURT
AND STATE COURT PRECEDENT THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE.
A FISH OUT.
AND MONEY SAVING REFORM.
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM THE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ALEXA MATHESON ON BEHALF OF NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CHAD INJURIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT.
OUR LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD.
ALRIGHT LET SOME CHEAP THERE'S
CALM ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THE
DíAS.
RIGHT THE BILL IS MOVED AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
HI.
CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS -- I
THINK WE HAVE.
SEEN.
A LOT OF MOVEMENT ON THIS ISSUE
OF THE FEES AND FINES BOTH
LEGISLATION BY.
MEMBERS OF OUR TWO HOUSES AS
WELL AS ACTION BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECOGNIZING.
NOT ONLY THE INABILITY TO
COLLECT IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THEY'RE SPENDING TRYING TO
COLLECT ON FEES AND FINES THAT
THEY CAN'T BUT ALSO THE IMPACT
IT HAS ON LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
AND I WATCHED A FASCINATING
DOCUMENTARY OVER THE WEEKEND ON
PUBLIC TELEVISION IT WAS SAID IT
WAS -- AROUND INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVED IN INDIANAPOLIS BUT IT
SHOWED A MAN WHO WAS -- HAD
FIRST BEEN CONVICTED OF A MINOR
CHARGE WHEN HE WAS YOUNG.
AND BUT AS A RESULT OF THAT WAS
THEN -- IT IMPACTED HIS ABILITY
TO GET JOBS AND SAID SHE WAS ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE RAISING HIS.
DAUGHTER ALONE WHO IS AN
EPILEPTIC.
AND HE THEN HE EITHER PARKING
EITHER PARKING VIOLATION OR SOME
OTHER -- TRAFFIC TYPE OF
VIOLATION WHICH THE FINDS GREW
TO SUCH A POINT THAT THERE WAS A
WARRANT OUT FOR HIS ARREST AND
AS HE WAS TRYING TO GET HIS
RECORDS SEALED HE HAD TO TURN
HIMSELF IN. FOR THAT WHICH
INCLUDE WHICH THEN ADDED ANOTHER
CONVICTION AND THEN STARTED OVER
THE CLOCK FOR WHEN HE COULD GET
IT SEALED SO HERE WAS A PERSON
WHO WAS.
BASICALLY DOING EVERYTHING HE
COULD TO GET HIMSELF IN A
SITUATION TO BE ABLE -- TO HAVE
THE KIND OF EMPLOYMENT THAT
WOULD ALLOW HIM TO BE OFFICES
STINTS IN SUPPORT HIMSELF IN HIS
DAUGHTER.
AND YET THESE SIR.
THE SEARCH SITUATIONS WERE JUST
CONTINUING TO PLAGUE AND IT WAS --
IT WAS BOTH HEART BREAKING AND
ALSO -- INSPIRING BUT IT HE'S HE
ANOTHER SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
AND WITHOUT WILL TAKE WILL WILL
ASK YOUR CLOTHES AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE A ROLL CALL.
MADAM CHAIR I WILL.
AS CHAIR PUBLISHED IN A PUBLIC
SAFETY I WILL.
TAKE YEAR ELOQUENT AND
THOUGHTFUL COMMENT AS MY CLOSE.
DATE WITH ZERO CALL.
BUSH'S THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER. FIVE I'M
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BROWN.
AROUND A WINNER.
I WIENER HIGH.
ALRIGHT WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL
AND NOW WE HAVE -- ITEMS
SEVENTEEN CORRECT AB.
TWELVE SIXTY ONE YOUR BILL ON
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
THANK YOU.
UP I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWELVE
SIXTY ONE A BILL THAT THAT
DELETES REQUIREMENT FOR
NARCOTICS OFFICERS TO REGISTER
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A PERSON
CONVICTED OF CERTAIN DRUG
OFFENSES REQUIRED TO REGISTER
WITH THEIR LOCAL POLICE CHIEF
FOR SHARE.
WHEN REGISTERING THE INDIVIDUALS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FINGERPRINTS
GET PHOTOGRAPHED AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION SUCH AS THEIR
ADDRESS DATE OF BIRTH DRIVER'S
LICENSE NUMBER OCCUPATION
ADDRESS AND VEHICLE INFORMATION?
EACH TIME A REGISTRANT MOVES
THEY ARE DIRECT REQUIRED TO RE
REGISTER WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GOING THROUGH THIS
SAME LABORIOUS PHOTOGRAPHING
FINGERPRINTING AND INFORMATION
GATHERING PROCESS.
THIS IS AN INEFFICIENT PROCESS
AND REDUNDANT GIVEN THAT ALL OF
THE INFORMATION PROVIDED IN THE
REGISTRY CAN BE FOUND IN THE
PERSONALS CRIMINAL RECORD.
IN ADDITION THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED IS NOT PUT INTO A
COLLECTED INDIVIDUALLY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY I BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S TIME AND
RESOURCES ARE BEING USED IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
ALSO BELIEVE AS IMPORTANT TO
REMOVE BARRIERS THAT PREVENT
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON THE
EXCESSIVE WORKLOAD ON THE COURT
SYSTEM.
REMOVING A REQUIREMENT TO
REGISTER.
AT FALLS IN LIBER RECENT POLICY
REFORM SUCH AS PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN AND SIXTY FOUR WHICH CALL
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
REHABILITATION PEOPLE RE
ENTERING INTO COMMUNITIES.
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION IS LARRY
DOYLE FROM THE CONFERENCE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATION'S
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
MAY POLICY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IT SEEMS TO BE A TENDENCY TO
KIND OF A QUITE THE NARCOTICS
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT WITH
THE SEXUAL OFFENDER REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENT BECAUSE THEY ARE
DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE REQUIRED DISTRICTS
REQUIREMENTS.
IT MAY BE A ONE TIME IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES THAT WAS.
RELATIVELY TRUE.
BUT THERE'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE
THE INFORMATION THAT GOES FOR
THE SEXUAL OFFENDERS
REGISTRATION.
IS MAINTAINED IN A CENTRAL
DATABASE PROVIDED TO THE PUBLIC
OF CALIFORNIA ONLINE THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE UNDER
MEGAN'S LAW.
AND IS -- THEREFORE OF SOME
VALUE IN THAT WAY THE SEXUAL THE
NARCOTICS REGISTRATION
INFORMATION.
IS SIMPLY A MASTER AT THE LOCAL
EVEL AND PROVIDE GOES
ABSOLUTELY NOWHERE THERE'S BEEN
NO EFFORT EVER MADE. TO MAKE A
STATEWIDE DATABASE IN THIS
COMPLETELY INCONSISTENT WITH THE
LAW CHANGES.
WE'VE MADE RECENTLY.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE IS A
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT WHICH
IMPOSES A GREAT BURDEN.
ON THE OFFENDERS BUT IT ALSO
IMPOSES A MASSIVE BURDEN ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MAINTAIN THIS
DATABASE.
IT DOESN'T PROVIDE ANYBODY WITH
ANYTHING VALUABLE AND IT'S A
REALLY TIME.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FACT AND
MOVE ON AND MAKE BETTER USE OF
OUR TIME RESOURCES.
SO -- WE HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT
THIS BILL FIVE MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS SOUGHT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- WE'VE GOT A
MOTION -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BACK FASTER
AYE VOTE.
EXCELLENT WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL.
ACTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI.
I'M MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
BY WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
TO BLOOD ARE FOLKS WHO ARE
MISSING OUT ON AND THANKS SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
NOW WE WILL GO TO I THINK IT'S I
BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I MEAN
RUBIO.
IS OF ROSE NEXT APOLOGY SO YOU
SO ITEM.
TWELVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROW.
THAT IS AB.
FIVE FIVE ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AS AMENDED EIGHTY FIVE FIVE ONE
SIMPLY WILL UPDATE CURRENT LAW
TO REQUIRE DRUG TESTING IN
ADDITION TO ALCOHOL TESTING
AFTER FATAL VEHICLE COLLISIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR -- WITH ME
TODAY'S JENNIFER HARMAN WITH THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE CRIME LAB IF
YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT.
YOU MAY.
PROCEED.
THE NUMBER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB.
FIVE FIVE ONE I AM JENNIFER
HARMON I'M CURRENTLY THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY CRIME LABORATORY
AND A FORENSIC TOXICOLOGIST FOR
NEARLY EIGHTEEN YEARS. EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY ONE IS AN EFFORT BY
SCIENTISTS BY TOXICOLOGISTS TO
IMPROVE THE FORENSIC TESTING AND
DATA COLLECTION ON FATALLY
INJURED DRIVERS.
DR LUKE RHODA CHIEF TOXICOLOGIST
AND LABORATORY DIRECTOROF THE
SAN FRANCISCO MEDICAL EXAMINER'S
OFFICE AND I BROUGHT THIS BILL
FORWARD TO OUR LEGISLATORS.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY PROVIDES
10% OF THE NATIONAL DATA TO THE
FATALITY ANALYSIS REPORTING
SYSTEM.
BETTER KNOWN AS FARCE MORE DATA
THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THIS DATA IS PROBLEMATIC AS THE
STATE HAS NOT UPDATED THE
GOVERNMENT AND VEHICLE CODES
THAT DICTATE TESTING.
ON FATALLY INJURED DRIVER CASES
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE CODE AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS
OBLIGATES CORNERS AND MEDICAL
EXAMINERS TO TEST FOR ALCOHOL
EXCLUSIVELY IN CASES WHERE
SOMEONE WAS FATALLY INJURED.
AND A DECISION IS TECH TO TEST
FOR OTHER POTENTIALLY IMPAIRING
SUBSTANCES IS LEFT UP TO THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT ENTITIES SET THE
PRIORITIES ABOUT WHAT DATA
SHOULD BE COLLECTED.
IN TRAFFIC RELATED CASES THAT
RESULT IN A DEATH.
IT LEAVES CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATION WITH LITTLE TO NO
RELIABLE DATA ON PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND TAX WHEN
SUBSTANCES IN ADDITION TO
ALCOHOL ARE INVOLVED.
IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS SUBSTANCE
USE AND FORENSIC TESTING
CAPABILITIES OF CHANGED.
THE COUNTRY IS IN CRISIS WITH AN
OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND ACCORDING TO
THE GOVERNORS HIGHWAY SAFETY
ASSOCIATION -- IMPAIRING
SUBSTANCES WERE PRESENT IN 43%
OF FATALLY INJURED DRIVERS THAT
WERE TESTED.
CALIFORNIA STATE TO STICKS MAY
BE GROSSLY UNDER REPORTING THE
PREVALENCE OF MANY SUBSTANCES IN
THESE CASES.
THIS ASSERTION IS FROM KNOWING
THAT CALIFORNIA CORNERS THE
MEDICAL EXAMINERS ARE NOT
OBLIGATED TO TEST TRAFFIC SAFETY
SUBSTANCES OTHER THAN ALCOHOL.
ORANGE COUNTY DATA ALONE THE
THIRD MOST POPULOUS COUNTY IN
THE STATE FOUND THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND 1862% OF OUR
FATALLY INJURED DRIVERS AT LEAST
ONE IMPAIRING SUBSTANCE IN THEIR
SYSTEM.
THIS IS A 6% INCREASE FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AND A 12%
INCREASE FROM.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AS
SCIENTISTS WE CANNOT UNDERSTAND
THE PROBLEM IF THERE IS IF THERE
IS A PROBLEM.
LET ALONE SOURCE SOLUTIONS TO
FIX IT WITHOUT MEANINGFUL DATA.
THIS BILL UPDATES THE CODES TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY
COLLECT DATA. TO UNDERSTAND IF
SUBSTANCE USE IS PRESENT
INCREASING OR DECREASING IN OUR
FATALLY INJURED TRAFFIC SAFETY
RELATED CASES.
AND ADDITIONALLY ENSURES THAT
ALL THE SEASONS OF TRAFFIC
RELATED INCIDENTS ARE TESTED THE
SAME WAY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU WHAT SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE WE HAVE IN
THE BILL AS AMENDED.
AND OUR DISCUSSION SENATOR
BRADFORD.
AND SHE CURES ON WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS WERE -- I THINK
THEY'RE IN THE NOTICES LET'S SEE --
SIR.
APOLOGIES OKAY I'M FINE I SHOULD
TAKES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- WE'VE GOT A MOTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
RESPECT LASHANDRA.
THANKS SO MUCH THE YES YES --
MORE LARK SENATOR MORE LUCK WITH
THE BILL YEAH.
SO THE BILL IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
MOTION IS.
SEVERAL CALL SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER I'M MORE LIKE MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE HIGH MORALE AYE WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
HOLD THE ROLE BECAUSE WE HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE MISSING BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION BILL LOOKS GOOD I
COULD CARE CENTERS OKAY.
NOW WE WILL GO TO OUR OUR LAST
ITEM WHICH IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
RUBIO.
AND THAT IS ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
TEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
TEN SEVENTY THREE WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TO ENTER INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT OR ICE TO LIMIT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES AT THE
VICTIM.
THE VICTIM SERVICE LOCATIONS
<c.magenta>ENTIONED IN THE ATTORNEY</c>
GENERAL'S OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MODEL POLICIES ON
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS A STATE
OR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
INCLUDING SCHOOL POLICE AND
SECURITY DEPARTMENT FROM USING
MONEY OR PERSONNEL TO
INVESTIGATE INTERROGATE.
DETAINED TACT -- ARREST PERSONS
FOR IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES.
SB FIFTY FOUR REQUIRED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ESTABLISH
MODEL POLICIES LIMITING
ASSISTANCE WITH IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE HAD ORGANIZATIONS REACH
OUT TO US AND INFORM US THAT
THEY HAVE SEEN A DECLINE IN
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS SEEKING
SERVICES FOR DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE SINCE ON TWENTY SIXTEEN
MOST UNDOCUMENTED SURVIVORS ARE
TOO AFRAID TO ASK FOR HELP.
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF BEING
RIPPED AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
I UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT. TO
ACT.
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO ASK FOR
HELP WITH PROPER DOCUMENTATION
AND I CAN IMAGINE DIED WITHOUT --
DOCUMENTS IT'S THAT MUCH HARDER.
LET ME BE CLEAR ICE CANNOT BE
PERMANENTLY STOPPED FROM
ENTERING THESE LOCATIONS.
HOWEVER AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
WILL HELP REMEDY THE FEARS BY
WORKING WITH THE ICE IN HELPING
PROTECT THE SURVIVORS IN THESE
LOCATIONS -- AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. TO THE JUDGE.
CHAD ANDREWS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY OTHERS ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEN.
NINE A WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND THE BILL IS.
WE DON'T HAVE AMENDMENTS CORRECT
IT WOULD BE TO PASS TO A PROBES.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I DON'T HAVE A
SENATOR CHECKS IN WITH HIM I
APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUAL
WORK ON THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- SOMETHING
DEAR TO MY HEART FOR THE LAST.
FORTY YEARS I HAVE TO ADMIT --
WE'VE NOT HAD ENOUGH SHELTERS
WE'VE NOT HAD ASSURANCES THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAFE IN THEIR
SHELTERS SO THAT WE HAVE KEPT
THEIR LOCATION SECRET. FOR
PURPOSES OF SAFETY AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU ADDRESS THIS BUT ONE
OF MY CONCERNS WAS -- HOW ICE
KNOWS WHERE THESE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTERS ARE LOCATED IN
THE FIRST PLACE -- BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION SUPPOSED TO BE
CONFIDENTIAL.
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE DISSEMINATED
AND PARTICULARLY THE HOSTILE
FEDERAL AGENCIES LIKE ICE SO HOW
HOW IS THAT ADDRESSED HERE FELT
SO WITH MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THEY ARE ICE CAN ONLY FIND THE
EXACT LOCATIONS. FOR ONE OF THE
SHELTERS WITH A WARRANT OR A
SUBPOENA -- NOTHING IN THIS BILL
WOULD PREVENT THIS FROM
OCCURRING WHEN ICE HAS OBTAINED
A WARRANT AND SO THIS IF THEY DO
FIND THE LOCATIONS THAN THIS
PREVENTS ICE FROM INTERROGATING
AND DOING ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DESCRIBED IN THE BILL.
I'M YOU KNOW THAT IF ONE PERSON
KNOWS AND EVERYBODY KNOWS AND I
KNOW THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE KEPT
SECRET BY UNDER SUBPOENA OR
WARRANT -- RIGHT CAN OBTAIN THE
DELIGHT YOU ARE SENSITIVE TO
THAT IN ONLY IF THEY GET THAT IF
THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MEET THAT BAR.
ARE THEY GOING TO THEN GET THE
INFORMATION GAS.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT YOU CAN CLOSE
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
AND PRECIADO AT THE GIVES THE
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL THE ABILITY
TO MAKE AGREEMENTS AND RESPECT
WHAT SENSITIVE LOCATIONS THESE
ARE -- AND WITH THAT WE'LL DO A
ROLL CALL.
MISSION IS TO PASS TO APPROACH
SKINNER HI THERE I MORE LOCK.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MORALE.
WELL KNOWN WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
OKAY BUT I CALL IT WE'RE GONNA --
ASKAR ABSENT MEMBERS COME BACK
IN LIFT CALLS BUT THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
SO I THINK WE'VE -- HEARD ALL
THE BILLS BUT WE STILL NEED TO
OPEN THE ROLE -- TO WE LET'S
START OPENING THE ROLE JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS
HERE WHO THEN COULD [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK ITEM ONE A. B..
TWELVE THE PAST AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ZERO
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MORALE.
AROUND THEM.
I WILL HOLD THE BILL STILL ON
CALL.
BUT WE DO -- THE MICHELIN WHO
MITCHELL HASN'T VOTED YET SO
OKAY.
AT ITEM TO AB SIXTY ONE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE AS CONSENT YEAH MITCHELL AND
MORALE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OKAY WE ARE TAKING THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE ARE OPENING THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR GO AHEAD READ
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MITCHELL
MORALE [inaudible]
MORALE HIGH.
THEY WILL KEEP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OPEN.
ITEM SIX AB THREE OH THREE SERVE
ON CASE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
THREE TO ZERO MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE MORALE.
WIENER AYE WIENER HIGH.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER. SIX AB
THREE OH THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SURVIVED CASE IT'S TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WERE YOU CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AGAIN ARE ALL.
HIGH MORALE HIGH. SEVEN ZERO
FOUR EIGHT EIGHTY THREE OH THREE
IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM SEVEN AB THREE
THREE NINE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS.
FORTY ZERO MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MITCHELL MORALE.
I WOULD FEDERAL WHICH ALLOWED ME
TO OUR HE SAID THAT HE SAID OKAY.
FIVE FIVE ONE AB THREE THREE
NINE IS OUT.
FIVE ONE ITEM EIGHT AB THREE
NINE ONE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ZERO
BRADFORD [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
PEROT.
HI MORRELL AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER HIGH.
THAT THOSE -- FIVE AB THREE NINE
ONE IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO ITEM. NINE EIGHTY
THREE NINE THREE NINE TO MOTIONS
TO PASS THE FLOOR AROUND
[inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
OKAY NUMBER.
THIRTY SIX OKAY AB THREE NINE
TWO IS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM TEN AB FOR
THIRTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
JACKSON.
OKAY MITCHELL HI MITCHELL ARE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
DID YOU READ MURROW IN A
BUILDING OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO AB FOR THIRTEEN IS
OUT.
FOUR ZERO ITEM TWELVE AB FIVE
FIVE ONE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
JACKSON.
HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MID JULY.
AB FIVE FIVE ONE IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX FOUR FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT FOCUS
FORTY ZERO MORE LOCK.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU.
THROWN DOWN [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY AB SIX FOUR FIVE IS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
NINE TWO SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
FOCUS FOUR TO ONE JACKSON.
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL ARE.
HOLD ON LET ME JUST ASK MS.
MS JACKSON WORK GOT THIS ROLE
OPEN -- NINE NINE VITAMIN --
WHICH ONE IS NINETY SEVENTY
JONES SAWYER BY.
JACKSON HIGH.
AB NINETY SEVEN IS OUT -- SIX TO
ONE OUT SIX TUNE ITEMS SIXTEEN
EIGHTY TEN SEVENTY THREE MOTIONS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE MORE
LOCK.
MITCHELL.
I'M SORRY BILL NUMBER THIS IS
RUBIO IS AB [inaudible]
TEN SEVENTY THREE JULY.
ALL RIGHT -- AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE IS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE ITEM SEVENTEEN A.
B. TWELVE SIXTY ONE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE IT'S FIVE TO ZERO JACKSON.
HI JACKSON HIGH MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARE.
AB TWELVE SIX ONE IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE MOTION IS.
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS.
SIX ZERO MOREAU.
MOREAU R..
A. B. OURTEEN TWENTY THREE IS
OUT.
SEVEN ZERO AT LAST WHAT
212-180-1650 TWO MOTIONS TO PASS
THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE IS SIXTY
ZERO MOREAU.
NOT.
OKAY AB SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO IS OUT
SIX ZERO AND WE HAVE TO
REMAINING I THINK TWO MAYBE
THREE REMAINING TO CALL LET'S RE
OPEN THOSE ITEMS ONE AB TWELVE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT ROE IN SUPPORT OF ONE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE.
OKAY AB TWELVE IS OUT.
FIVE ONE YEAH ITEM FOR WHICH IS
THE CAN THANK OUT -- CALENDAR
THAT.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO ZERO
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARE. THREE CONSENT
CALENDARS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO LET'S CHECK.
THAT WAS PULLED.
YES OKAY.
I THINK WE'VE GOT YOU ON ALL OF
THEM.
WE WE'VE NOW GOT SENATOR
MITCHELL AND EVERYTHING ALL
RIGHT EXCELLENT.
SO WITH THAT [inaudible]
THE BILLS INVOLVING HEARD NOT
BEEN VOTED ON AND OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU ADJOURN